nous avons le plaisir de recevoir à
nouveau monsieur est mise l'intérieur
sur le projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur dont nous commençons
l'examen ce matin
ce projet de loi avait fait l'objet
d'une première version déposée au mois
de mars sur le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale et après les élections
présidentielles législatives le
gouvernement a déposé le 7 septembre
2022 sur le bureau du Sénat une nouvelle
version plus courte plus resserrée ce
dont je le félicite et c'est car cela
permettra d'avoir un débat plus cohérent
et centré sur les priorités du ministère
intérieur pour les 5 prochaines années
ainsi que sur la programmation
budgétaire qui ne représente pas moins
de 15 milliards d'euros de crédit
supplémentaire prévu sur la période le
Sénat a largement adopté le projet de
loi le 18 octobre par 300C de voix
contre 27 et n'a ajouté que 5 articles
additionnels au 16 qui étaient les 16
articles initiaux du texte monsieur le
mixte vous allez d'abord nous présenter
les grandes lignes de ce projet de loi
puis nous écouterons le rapporteur
Florent Boudier ensuite je donnerai la
parole aux rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de la défense Monsieur Xavier
battu il y a un orateur par groupe pour
une durée de 4 minutes le ministre
répondra et je pourrais donner la parole
aux différents orateurs qui souhaiteront
poser une question ces questions durée
maximale de 2 minutes
monsieur le ministre dans le silence
vous avez la parole
le seul président de la commission des
lois monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés merci une nouvelle
fois de de m'inviter aux travaux de
votre commission puisque vous étudiez la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur une loi très
importante importante d'abord par le
fait évidemment que nous ne vous
demandons 15 milliards de crédits
nouveaux supplémentaires il faut mesurer
ce que cela signifie le quinquennat
précédent tout confondu et 10 milliards
de dépenses supplémentaires sur 5 ans
c'est 15 milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires soit 50 qui viennent on
l'énorme avantage par ailleurs d'être
dans une programmation ce qui n'est
jamais arrivé au ministère de
l'Intérieur il y a eu des lois
d'orientation et de sécurité intérieure
des fameuses lobsi il a pu avoir des
lois de programmation des forces de
sécurité intérieure lorsque ministère
d'intérieur avait un périmètre plus
petit c'est le cas des années 80 mais il
n'a jamais eu de loi de programmation
pour l'ensemble du ministère de
l'Intérieur sécurité civile sécurité
au sens très large immigration
intégration agent de préfecture et
fonctionnement de l'ensemble des
services publics qui sont sous désormais
mon autorité à la demande du président
et de la première ministre et c'est toi
de programmation budgétaire elle permet
de pouvoir d'abord détailler la feuille
de route que nous souhaitons mettre en
place pour dans 5 ans et de pouvoir
programmer budgétairement des
transformations notamment numériques et
cyber extrêmement importante comme les
militaires ont une loi de programmation
militaire c'est à dire pour cela que
nous proposons vous le savez bien cette
loi de programmation en tant que tel je
pense qu'on a beaucoup détaillé monsieur
le Président le texte je vais faire une
de très courte introduction parce que je
crois que le plus intéressant évidemment
c'est que nous puissions échanger sur
les prises de position et surtout les
amendements qui ont été déposés je
voudrais d'abord saluer le travail que
nous avons pu faire au Sénat vous avez
vous-même souligné que une large
majorité des sénateurs alors DLR
jusqu'au groupe socialiste évidemment
avec les sénateurs de la majorité
parlementaire de l'Assemblée nationale
ont adopté ce texte bien sûr tout n'est
pas
accepté par l'ensemble des sénateurs
mais je crois qu'ils ont vu l'effort
financier très important la volonté de
répondre finalement aux cinq crises qui
s'imposent à nous et c'est ça ce texte
c'est gérer les cinq crises qui vont
s'imposer à la France quel que soit les
majorités quel que soit les dirigeants
politiques et je voudrais d'ailleurs en
premier lieu saluer les agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur les policiers
les gendarmes les agents de sécurité
civile des agents de préfecture il
m'excuser par avance de ne pas être à
vos travaux de commission demain puisque
je vais présider aux obsèques du
gendarme qui a été tué vous le savez
dans l'heure et donc ce qui me permet de
rappeler évidemment que au ministres de
l'Intérieur non seulement nous avons des
agents publics quel qu'il soit quel que
soit leur grade leur fonction ou la
façon dont ils ne gère leur carrière qui
sont évidemment très
très courageux mais que par ailleurs il
paye du prix de leur vie leur engagement
pour la France et pour la fonction
publique je veux évidemment rappeler les
cinq crises qui vont toucher notre pays
et pour lequel il s'est à l'intérieur
doit prévoir des moyens politiques après
les avoir défini des cas du rapport
annexé assez long que nous avons proposé
et puis les moyens budgétaires qui
accompagnent ces objectifs politiques
d'abord il y a évidemment une crise
que nous pourrions considérer comme
étant une crise d'ordre public on l'a vu
dans les manifestations précédentes les
gilets jaunes en son exemple premier
c'est fini les manifestations à la papa
c'est fini le fait que nous puissions
tous
considérer que nous connaissons par
avance qui va manifester avec des
services d'ordre de syndicats organisés
dans une seule ville de France nous
devons désormais faire face à des
manifestations spontanées numériques peu
prévisible et l'ordre public c'est un
métier
ce n'est pas un métier que peut faire
n'importe quelle policier n'importe quel
gendarme c'est un métier qui connaît une
formation spécifique d'où notamment la
recréation de 15 unités de force mobile
supplémentaire je rappelle que
11 pardon unités supplémentaire je
rappelle que 15 avaient été supprimé
dans les 20 dernières années nous
recréons pour la première fois cette
escadron de gendarmerie mobile 4
compagnies de Cérès pourquoi d'ailleurs
cette Escada gendarmerie mobile parce
qu'il y a des crises dans des crises
notamment dans les crises ultramarines
que nous pouvons connaître vous savez
bien que c'est l'apanage des gendarmes
extrêmement souvent que d'être envoyé
sur les territoires en crise
l'organisation des référendums en
Nouvelle-Calédonie ça a été le cas
l'hiver dernier évidemment des sujets
qui se posent à Mayotte ou en Guyane
nous en reparlerons sans doute
avec la crise de l'ordre public n'est
deuxième crise qu'elle a crie cyber qui
est l'objet d'ailleurs essentiel des
crédits que nous vous demandons puisque
sur les 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires plus de la moitié sont
pour le cyber et pour le numérique au
ministère de l'intérieur soit pour
simplifier la vie des policiers des
gendarmes aux agents préfecture
eux-mêmes une faire l'impôt à la source
finalement au ministère de l'Intérieur
veut simplifier un centre de procédure
qui aujourd'hui démobilisent nos agents
qui me disent qu'ils sont pris par la
paperasse ou par les difficultés de
discussion avec les citoyens ou avec la
justice mais bien sûr et surtout si
j'ose dire lutter contre la menace
nouvelle qui est la menace du cyber
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié notamment
des escroqueries que nous connaissons
sont déjà des esprits cyber et nous
savons que demain
la crise que nous allons connaître cyber
va toucher de manière considérable le
secret des correspondances ces activités
économiques des plus petites PME de vos
circonscriptions les hôpitaux publics
que bien évidemment que l'attentat
lui-même ne sera sans doute plus celui
qui sera caractér par un homme qui
rentre avec une kalachnikov une salle de
spectacle même si évidemment ce sujet
peut toujours arriver mais que ce sera
un drone chargé d'explosif qui ira sur
une foule en même temps que les feux
rouges de la capitale pour être attaqué
par une attaque cyber ainsi que les
hôpitaux prévus dans le plan blanc et là
ce n'est pas quelques dizaines ou
quelques centaines de morts mais
potentiellement des milliers de morts au
sens littéral du terme bien évidemment
auquel nous devons nous préparer et
c'est pour ça que les les crises que
nous connaissons dans le monde militaire
parce que les attaques de drones armés
existent dans les opérations extérieures
aujourd'hui vont évidemment s'importer
dans le monde de la politique de la
sécurité intérieure et nous devons voir
comment nous pouvons répondre à cette
crise terroriste nouvelle ces menaces
nouvelles et le cyber évidemment en fait
particulier en partie dans dans ce que
désormais nous appelons la guerre
hybride et qui a connu son son arrivée
si j'ose dire pour les Français pendant
le conflit
ukrainien après la crise d'ordre public
après la crise cyber nous avons
évidemment une crise de sécurité civile
du réchauffement climatique les les feux
de cet été ont démontré à quel point le
réchauffement climatique n'ont pas qu'il
en soit particulièrement responsable a
priori mais qu'il donne les conditions
évidemment de la diffusion des
intempéries que nous connaissons et
notamment des feux fait que nous avons
besoin de renforcer de manière
absolument considérable nos moyens de
sécurité civile songez que la moitié des
feux de cet été au lieu au nord de la
Loire et non plus simplement si j'ose
dire dans les départements que nous
connaissions habitués au feu de forêt la
Corse les Vars les Bouches-du-Rhône les
Alpes-Maritimes lorsque le Jura est
concerné lorsque la Bretagne connaît des
milliers d'hectares qui brûlent lorsque
la Maine-et-Loire connaît des milliers
d'hectares qui brûlent cet été nous
devons adapter nos systèmes aériens nos
systèmes d'intervention évidemment qui
coûte beaucoup d'argent dont la loopy
d'ailleurs avant même les annonces du
président de la République qui seront
complétés monsieur le Président pendant
le débat budgétaire et le débat de la de
la lotmi être au rendez-vous de cette
crise de sécurité civile qui fait naître
aussi un quinquennat qui n'a connu les
pires intempéries de notre histoire
récente nous avons commencé le
quinquennat précédent par Irma à
Saint-Martin nous l'avons quasiment
terminé avec la Vésubie et la Roya
à la fin du quinquennat on voit bien que
indépendamment des feux des questions
relevant du réchauffement climatique et
l'intervention du ministère de
l'Intérieur puisque la responsabilité en
moyenne technologique et en moyenne
technique et humains et très important
après la crise d'ordre public après la
crise cyber après la crise de sécurité
civile je veux évidemment souligner
l'importance de la lutte contre la
délinquance et nouvelle forme de
délinquance qui sont aujourd'hui au
rendez-vous de notre constat et qui vont
s'aggraver demain en complément
d'ailleurs de la de la crise cyber les
points de Deal demain seront en très
grande partie numérique nous aurons à
saisir des actifs financiers ce que nous
ne pouvons pas faire c'est d'ailleurs le
principe même d'ailleurs d'un des
articles de loi de de cette locmi euh et
nous ne pouvons pas
ignorer que une grande partie de
l'argent sale désormais circule de
manière numérique et que les
dispositions technologiques comme la
crypto ou les moyens
de téléphonique moderne nous empêche que
fait que les écoutes téléphoniques
classiques des moyens de présence sur la
voie publique on considérablement changé
notre intervention et je ne parle même
pas de la voiture autonome qui dans 7 ou
8 ans on va complètement changer la
façon dont les motards par exemple
seront des contrôles autoroutiers
évidemment il faut réfléchir à tous à
tous ce sujet d'où d'ailleurs des moyens
extrêmement importants mis en formation
initiaux et continue dans ce texte de
loi on aura l'occasion d'en reparler et
il y a un objectif simple que le
doublement de la présence de la voie
publique et je crois que nous détaillons
très largement comment on atteint ce
doublement de la présence sur la voie
publique à la fois en faisant des
réformes internes de ministère de
l'Intérieur je pense aussi que l'horaire
en augmentant les effectifs 8500
policiers gendarmes et agents préfecture
demandés dans ce texte de loi la
recréation parlant des 200 brigades de
gendarmerie après avoir supprimer 5 en
30 ans démontrent je crois ce sujet de
présence de voie publique on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler c'est vraiment
l'objet sans doute principal du rapport
indexé que vous avez eu dans votre
article premier et puis cinquièmement
j'en terminerai peut-être pas là une
crise de l'investigation qu'il a fait le
lien avec le travail que fait le mistral
justice qui aura l'occasion de présenter
un texte de procédure pénale et code
pénale il n'appartient pas au ministère
de l'Intérieur de présenter évidemment
des textes qui relèvent du ministre de
la justice mais l'investigation la façon
dont on qualifie les officiers de
préjudiciaires les assistantes d'enquête
recréés qui sont des formes de greffiers
de de police que mes dégréfillé de
justice va de pair évidemment avec la
difficulté que nous connaissons toutes
et tous puisque nous avons mis de plus
en plus de personnes sur la voie
publique dans le quinquennat précédent
il y a à peu près une vingtaine de pour
cent de trafiquants ou de délinquants
interpellé de manière supplémentaire
mais il faut évidemment faire des
enquêtes il faut évidemment les produire
il faut les présenter à la justice et
dans la réponse pénale qui nous paraît
parfois décevante il y a beaucoup de
travail incomplet des services du
ministère de l'intérieur par manque de
PJ vous le savez bien dans chacun de vos
territoires voilà ce que je voudrais
dire en quelques mots monsieur le
Président peut-être terminé puisque
comme je l'aurai pas le bonheur d'être
avec vous demain en commission pour les
raisons que j'ai évoqué mais que si vous
m'avez invité je serai là vendredi pour
vous dire que c'est vraiment avec
l'esprit
si vous m'avez je serai là vendredi donc
je suis à disposition je suis à
disposition du Parlement je voudrais
dire d'abord que c'est vraiment un
esprit très ouvert parce que je crois
que c'est un texte très républicain que
que nous que que nous proposons que nous
avons travaillé au Cénacle nous
travaillons à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
vu les amendements déposés par
l'ensemble des groupes et d'abord par
votre apporteur plus de près de 70
amendements déposés par le rapporteur
lui-même qui vont donc améliorer le
texte avec qui je donne un avis
favorable si j'ose dire comme elle-même
je ne serai pas en commission pour les
porter je me permets peut-être de
souligner monsieur le le Président si
vous me le permettez ça permettra de
connaître peut-être pour la Commission
de la vie du gouvernement même s'il
n'est pas là parce que effectivement je
ne pourrais pas être présent tout le
temps même si ce matin j'ai loupé le
Conseil des ministres pour vous ce qui
montre
la passion que j'ai pour pour vous-même
la nouvelle rédaction des articles de
l'article 4 qui permet de créer de créer
des
des contraintes à l'appel d'air supposés
sur les rangs logicielles à un avis
favorable évidemment du gouvernement et
la réécriture de partout d'où elles
viennent sera accompagné par le par le
gouvernement on aura l'occasion sans
doute d'avoir se débattre très
intéressant dans l'hémicycle puisque les
rançons logiciels sont une évidemment
des attaques cyber que nous connaissons
le plus c'est que nous connaîtrons le
plus semblable aux extorsions que sans
doute des années 80-90 ont pu connaître
je veux donner un avis favorable par
principe et par conviction aux
amendements sur le collège de
déontologie lui dire d'ailleurs par
ailleurs que j'en ai parlé avec le
rapporteur peut-être même qu'on peut
l'étendre à l'ensemble du ministère de
l'Intérieur et pas simplement à force de
sécurité intérieure il y a d'autres
sujets la dlpagi d'immigration qui peut
être concerné par le collège géologique
et le créé un amendement déposé par
Monsieur Ciotti sur la création de place
encras supplémentaires aura un avis
favorable de la part du gouvernement
puisque nous avons à peu près prévu 1500
places de centre de rétention
administratif supplémentaire je crois
que des amendements du député ce titre
prévoit 3000 places c'est-à-dire le
doublement et nous l'accompagnerons nous
voterons favorablement le sujet
simplement dire aux députés ciotiques
que ils prévoient des crédits en
investissement mais pas en
fonctionnement donc il faudra qu'on
discute aussi de la trajectoire
budgétaire avec le fonctionnement on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler un
amendement de de
Monsieur negelen sur la profond de la
consultation pour les 200 brigades de
gendarmerie en prévoyant un délai dit-il
raisonnable d'échanges sera évidemment
accepté l'idée qu'on est quelques mois
pour travailler sur l'implantation de
ces 200 brigades de gendarmerie c'est
tout à fait juste qu'une fois le fait en
constatation totale avec les élus je
veux dire Madame rigole que l'officier
de liaison LGBT plus pour nous
évidemment et
l'endroits que j'ai accepté du groupe
écologie au Sénat
pour
Monsieur Boucard et extensions des de
l'hypothèse des infractions de violence
contre les forces de l'ordre et les élus
pour la peine complémentaires je
donnerai un avis également favorable
monsieur bernalicis
de députés d'Europe écologie des Verts
sur la visioplinte voudrait faciliter je
crois la démarche des victimes et non la
simple bonne administration de la
justice en mettant la victime je suis
tout à fait favorable je crois que c'est
vraiment 295 et 638 on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler sans doute monsieur
balanon évoque les circonstances
aggravantes sur les outrages sexistes
j'y donnerai également un avis favorable
comme ses amendements avec
la circonstance aggravante pour
l'outrage sexy sur l'identité de genre
monsieur Boucard ainsi que Madame
pouziref sur les extensions des AFD et
sur les rodéo je pense trouveront un
avis favorable de notre part évidemment
sur la question
de de de dérodéo urbain ou elle a
beaucoup ils ont beaucoup travaillé sur
cette question en lien avec la maman qui
nous a été imposé mais avec notre avis
favorable au Sénat monsieur Ciotti nous
impose des traitements de le franc 60
jours c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de la loi
immigration qui qui va arriver donc un
avis favorable le principe et alors
Monsieur pardon
c'est pas de ma faute vous l'aurez
chacun leur a constaté mais on aura
l'occasion de reparler dans le
rémigration
pardon monsieur le Président et pour
[Musique]
midi je veux lui dire que je suis
favorable à son abonnement qui a 393
soit l'évaluation à terme de la plainte
en ligne vous aurez donc compris que sur
les 700 amendements déposés par
l'ensemble des groupes j'ai plus d'une
centaine voire un avis favorable de la
part du gouvernement il est évident que
dans le débat parlementaire pour ceux
qui me connaissent savent que je suis
plus mon instinct que les feuilles
devant rédigées par des collaborateurs
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur Florent Boudier
oui merci monsieur le Président merci le
monsieur le ministre bon votre votre
intervention de Monsieur le Ministre est
à l'image de la façon dont nous avons
souhaité conduire nos travaux au cours
des dernières semaines c'est-à-dire un
esprit de très grande ouverture esprit
de construction de ligne qui puisse être
l'objet de la consensus large à l'image
d'ailleurs de la position du Sénat
puisque je rappelle que la locmi a été
adoptée très largement au Sénat voici
maintenant quelques semaines le 12
octobre il me semble nous avons mené en
quatre semaines ce qui est un temps
relativement confortable pour préparer
l'examen en commission puis en séance
nous avons mené au total près de 25
auditions auditionné environ 70 à 80
personnes pour environ 30 heures
d'audition donc un travail très
constructif et puis je dois aussi
souligner ce qui est assez exceptionnel
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre que beaucoup de nos collègues
députés ont souhaité participer
à ces auditions généralement le
rapporteur est un peu seul dans ces
auditions il y avait un très grand
nombre de députés qui ont souhaité
accompagner ces travaux sur des sujets
aussi essentiels par exemple que la
question des rançons logicielles je
pense que la table ronde que nous avons
pu connaître était particulièrement
intéressantes et instructif pour la
façon dont nous pouvons aborder ce sujet
dans la loopmie je pense aussi à la
question des plaintes en
visio-conférence dont nous avons pu voir
pour celles et ceux qui étaient présents
en audition à quel point elle était
attendue des associations qui viennent
en aide aux femmes en particulier qui
ont été victimes de violence c'est donc
dans cet état d'esprit monsieur monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président que
nous abordons cette discussion vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le Ministre ce
projet de loi vient après le Livre blanc
de septembre 2020 qui lui-même faisait
l'objet d'une démarche très ouverte
puisqu'il avait été y compris élargie à
des universitaires par exemple
euh fait suite bien sûr au beau de la
sécurité de septembre 2020 21 il prend
un engagement considérable 15 milliards
d'euros qui font suite au 10 milliards
d'euros du quinquennat précédent un
engagement de d'emploi à temps plein
équivalentin et PP à 8500 ce qui est
absolument considérable dans 7612 pour
les seuls forces de sécurité intérieure
je crois même qu'à travers certains nous
le verrons amendements de suppression il
est reconnu que l'effort est intense au
point parfois de considérer qu'il est
trop intense pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur je parle en particulier des
amendements déposés par le groupe et les
filles mais nous aurons l'occasion dans
d'en reparler cette au fond monsieur le
ministre un exercice
qui n'est pas une tradition pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur auquel vous
avez souhaité soumettre nos débats la
dernière loi de programmation de 2011 il
y a 11 ans dans une époque tout à fait
différente de la nôtre avec des
phénomènes à la fois de délinquance
le domaine notamment liés à la sécurité
civile vous avez parlé des mégafeux qui
n'étaient pas encore aussi intenses il y
a 11 ans et donc la nécessité pour la
représentation nationale sur votre
proposition monsieur le ministre de
définir une trajectoire pour les 5 ans
qui viennent c'est à la fois l'article
premier le rapport annexe nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre à la fin de nos
travaux et puis l'article 2 je le disais
à l'instant je ne reviendrai pas
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président sur l'ensemble des articles
je n'ai pas les balayer à l'instant nous
aurons l'occasion de le faire dans nos
débats je voudrais simplement souhaiter
pour achever ma très courte prise de
parole souhaitait que l'état d'esprit
qui a été le nôtre en amont de l'examen
par la Commission
c'est à dire de chercher à construire
des solutions de consensus d'aller
regarder très précisément comment
fonctionne le droit existant sur tel ou
telle situation de voir en quoi il faut
l'adapter le cas échéant je pense au
débat que nous aurons par exemple sur
les enquêtes sous pseudonymes ou
certains arguments ne paraissent pas
tout à fait valable après que nous ayons
pu examiner réfléchir à ces sujets
notamment au cours des auditions je
pense que nous pourrions trouver
très large consensus autour des
ambitions monsieur le ministre qui sont
affichés à travers cette loi de
programmation
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la défense mais si vous avez battu
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues en préambule
je salue le courage et gendarmes mobiles
ayant fait face à des actes de violence
grave par certains activistes le
week-end dernier à saint-sauline j'ai
une pensée toute particulière pour les
61 gendarmes blessés en intervention je
concentrerai mes propos sur le champ de
saisine de la commission de la défense
les dispositions relatives à la
gendarmerie figurant aux articles 1 et 2
du projet de loi né dans le rapport
annexée lorsque notre majorité arriver
aux responsabilités en 2017 les forces
de sécurité intérieure revenaient de
loin que ce soit en matière d'effectif
ou d'investissement cet égard le
quinquennat 2017-2022 marque une rupture
profonde avec les deux mandats
précédents notre gouvernement a fait de
la remontée en puissance des forces de
gendarmerie de police une priorité de sa
politique cette remontée en puissance a
commencé par une hausse des effectifs
dans le cadre du plan 10000 puis le plan
de relance a permis aux gendarmes de
renouveler leur parc de véhicules et de
moto mais aussi de commander des
hélicoptères bus h160 dans le domaine de
l'équipement la gendarmerie a connu un
véritable une véritable révolution
numérique au cœur de la stratégie jantes
20 24 qui repose sur une logique d'aller
vers ou de pas de porte les téléphones
nés aux gens des ordinateur
ubiquity permettent aux gendarmes
d'effectuer en déplacement toutes les
missions ordinaire accomplies dans les
locaux des voyages dans le domaine
immobilier les gendarmes ont bénéficié
du plan poignet de porte et d'un
programme de rénovation enfin en 2021 le
bobo de la sécurité encore renouvelé en
renflouer les crédits à louer aux
gendarmes comme nos policiers une fois
arrêt lu notre majorité a décidé d'aller
encore plus loin avec le projet avec le
dépôt d'un projet de loi de
programmation en crant le mouvement dans
le long terme ce texte prévoit un effort
supplémentaire de 3,5 milliards d'euros
sur 5 ans au profit de la gendarmerie
concrètement le point saillant de la
loopnie pour les gendarmes réside dans
la création de 200 brigades de cet
escadron de gendarmerie et de 350 postes
de gendarmes
les nouvelles boyades classiques ou
intinérande viseront un rôle densifier
le maillage en zone rurale et à tenir
compte de l'augmentation de la
population en zone gendarmerie tous les
départements profiteront de ses
créations déjà entamés le travail de
concertation avec les élus sur les lieux
d'implantation des unités devraient se
terminer à la mi-janvier la loopmie
prévoit par ailleurs la montée en
puissance de la réserve opérationnelle
de niveau 1 de 30000 actuellement à
50000 d'ici 2027 avec une forte
augmentation en début de mandat pour
préparer les Jeux olympiques de Paris
j'ai déjà évoqué la transformation
numérique un numérique qui
paradoxalement rapproche plutôt
qu’éloigne
en matière en matière de formation les
élèves gendarmes passeront de 12 mois au
lieu de 8 en école de formation continue
sera consolidée avec la création de 1313
Giono enfin le protocole social conclut
le 9 mars dernier pour un montant de 197
millions d'euros profitera
particulièrement aux sous-officier qui
verront leur risque un discer de
valoriser ainsi qu'aux personnel de
soutien la commission de la défense
approuve des évolutions introduites par
le Sénat il s'agissant de la
programmation de 300 millions d'euros de
crédit immobilier pour les gendarmes ou
de 25 jours d'emploi pour les
réservistes nous avons quant à nous
adopté cinq amendements il concerne
l'instauration de passerelles entre les
différentes réserves mais aussi entre le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
le service national universel nous avons
aussi voulu rappeler la nécessité d'un
plein d'investissement des forces de
sécurité intérieure dans le service
national universel j'espère que votre
commission approuvera ses propositions
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci messieurs le rapporteur je vais
donner la parole aux orateurs des
groupes en commençant par Marie le bec
pour le groupe Renaissance
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous débutons aujourd'hui les débats
attendus de longue date sur le projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur dit la Love Me
qui fixera nos grandes orientations
stratégiques en matière de sécurité
publique et décidera des moyens
budgétaires qui seront mobilisés et
sanctuarisés pour la période 2023 2027
ce projet de loi est la traduction
concrète des engagements pris lors du
Bovo de la sécurité que vous avez animé
et coordonnées monsieur le ministre je
tiens à cet égard à souligner comme l'a
fait mon collègue rapporteur Florent
Boudier le sérieux du travail accompli
de toutes les parties prenantes qu'on
vient pour l'occasion Audi apaion
d'autres grandes lois d'orientation
adoptée sous le précédent quinquennat la
locmic consacrera un engagement pris par
le Président de la République devant les
Français l'objectif de ce texte est
clair modernisé et renforcer notre
politique publique de sécurité afin
qu'elle soit plus efficace forte et
juste pour répondre à toutes les formes
de violence des incivilités du quotidien
à la petite délinquance jusqu'au
terrorisme et la criminalité organisée
les moyens humains techniques et
financiers seront au rendez-vous pour
relever ces défis cette ambition sera en
effet soutenue par des moyens sans
précédents le budget du ministère de
l'Intérieur sera ainsi augmenté de 15
milliards d'euros entre 2023 et 2027
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre ce texte s'inscrit dans le
prolongement et en cohérence avec les
politiques que notre majorité ont
conduite ces cinq dernières années en
effet entre 2017 et 2022 nous avons créé
pas moins de 10000 postes de policiers
gendarmes augmenter le budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur et adopter
plusieurs lois confortant et renforçant
la sécurité de nos concitoyens
enfin pour mieux prévenir les nouvelles
menaces le renforcement de notre modèle
de gestion de crise avec des nouveaux
moyens humains et technologiques
supplémentaires je pense notamment à la
modernisation de notre système de
communication grâce à la mise en place
du réseau radio du futur mais également
à la formation d'epg et d'APG
supplémentaire pour mieux cibler les
missions les plus difficiles ou les plus
exposées soulignons et saluons à ce
propos les avancées du texte adopté au
Sénat qui ont permis de préciser encore
le texte et de prendre en compte les
réserves formulées par le Conseil d'État
je pense aux amandes forfaitaire
délictuelles je fais aussi référence à
la création de l'article 7 bis qui
renforce la réponse pénale pour prévenir
et interdire les rodéo urugmains et je
tenais à saluer la proposition du
gouvernement d'inscrire endur l'article
5 portant sur le réseau radio du futur
il nous est cependant apparu que le
texte pouvait être encore précisé à
l'occasion de l'examen de quelques
articles la majorité proposera donc de
réécrire l'article 4 portant sur les
auteurs de rançongiciel une entreprise
sur 5 déclare avoir subi au moins une
attaque par an son logiciel au cours de
l'année cette réalité cette réalité
commandait donc une réaction à la
hauteur des conséquences comporte cette
nouvelle criminalité ce texte contient
des avancées qui permettront de répondre
aux attentes des forces de l'ordre des
acteurs de la chaîne pénale mais aussi
de répondre aux légitimes exigences de
nos concitoyens qui aspirent à une plus
grande sécurité dans le strict respect
de nos valeurs et des principes de la
République je ne doute pas que ces
débats seront marqués du saut de cette
double ambition et que le sens des
responsabilités l'emportera sur tout
autre considération je je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Jordan Guitton pour le
groupe rassemblement national où était
le chronomètre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue le débat qui s'enclenche
aujourd'hui est fondamental la sécurité
l'une des préoccupations principales des
Français car elle est la première des
libertés au sein du groupe rassemblement
national nous nous réjouissons de
l'initiative d'une noix de programmation
pour votre ministère que nous demandions
avec Marine Le Pen malheureusement cette
loi est insuffisante et incomplète et
nous vous en déplaise monsieur le
ministre votre loi ne sera efficace que
si elle est suivie d'une volonté
politique que votre gouvernement n'a
jamais eu et d'une justice qui appliquer
réellement des peines ce qui est loin
d'être le cas avec le garde des sauts
actuels insuffisante d'abord sur
l'aspect budgétaire puisque les 15 sur
les 15 milliards d'euros le budget de
votre ministère n'augmente que 1,2
milliards pour 2023 puis seulement de
880 millions pour l'année 2024 ne
regrettons qu'il n'y ait pas
d'investissement massif dès les
premières années car la situation
sécuritaire l'exige incomplète également
parce que vous ne donnez pas
suffisamment de moyens nos forces de
l'ordre pour lutter contre la
délinquance et l'insécurité rien de
concret dans ce projet de loi pour les
protéger aucune mesure pour mettre en
place la présomption de légitime défense
pour nos forces de l'ordre qui autant
demander et qui serait temps légitime
pour eux rien également dans ce projet
de loi sur une réforme du sursis ou des
aménagements de peine encore bien trop
nombreux aucun mot sur une possible
revalorisation salariale des carrières
de nos forces de l'ordre qui risque
chaque jour leur vie et qui ont
l'impression sans cesse d'être une
variable d'ajustement des budgets rien
afin de faire appliquer pleinement les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français véritable faille de vos
gouvernement à l'instar de cette loi
vous avez beaucoup communiqué dessus
mais vous n'y avez rien changé sur les
outre-mer nous aurions souhaité voir
apparaître dans ce projet de loi plus de
mesures pour lutter contre l'insécurité
et leur spécificité rien n'y est proposé
rien non plus sur la mise en place
obligatoire nous police municipale dans
les villes de plus de 10 000 habitants
police municipale qui est la grande
oubliée de votre projet de loi il faut
le dire avec les pouvoirs de police des
mers qui devraient être légitimement
renforcé en bref le rassemblement
national aurait souhaité voir un projet
de loi plus ambitieux avec une incidence
beaucoup plus rapide à la star de suivi
de Marine Le Pen enfin monsieur le
ministre sur la structure de votre loi
vous nous avez présenté 16 articles
contre 33 initialement et 22 dans la
version adoptée par le Sénat faut-il y
voir une baisse de vos ambitions le
rapport annexé nous présente votre
vision politique en faisant fit de la
réalité quotidienne des Français j'y
vois plus un blabla pour vous ambitions
futures que des engagements concrets au
service des Français l'augmentation des
effectifs de police pour 2023 est faite
pour préparer les deux grands événements
sportifs internationaux en France avec
la Coupe du monde de rugby en 23 et les
JO en 24 mais pas pour servir nos
territoires d'ailleurs je vous souhaite
à ce propos monsieur le ministre qu'il
n'y ait pas trop d'anglais qui prennent
des billets pour ses compétitions
qu'elle nous donnerions encore une image
à l'international d'un pays sans loi ni
état en réalité par cette loi vous
rattrapez la suppression des policiers
de gendarmes de votre ancien parti
politique au pouvoir la suppression des
peines planchers sera d'ailleurs à
débattre bien plus tard dans cette
commission puis vous rattrapez le retard
pris dans l'investissement de la
criminité sur internet mais à l'instar
monsieur le ministre du lapin dans Alice
au pays des merveilles qui courent après
le temps vous vous courez après
l'insécurité résultat de dizaines
d'années de laxisme et de budget
inadapté à la réalité française
vous êtes un ministre excusez-moi du
terme à réaction enfin votre position
vis-à-vis de celle d'Eric Dupond-Moretti
et l'illustration parfaite de l'EN même
temps macroniste vous voulez renforcer
les effectifs de la police et de la
gendarmerie mais vous laissez les mains
du ministère de la Justice au ministre
du laxisme pour conclure comme à notre
habitude nous voterons ce qui est bon
pour les Français quel que soit la
couleur politique de celui qui propose
l'amendement et nous en demanderons bien
plus nous serons constructifs ferme
comme notre habitude car nous serons
toujours du côté de l'ordre et des
forces de l'ordre je vous remercie
monsieur gobernal ici sur le groupe la
France insoumise
merci monsieur le Président le sujet que
nous examinons aujourd'hui c'est toi
d'orientation doit être considérée
regarde un certain nombre de principes
quels sont les buts que nous poursuivons
que nous devrions tous poursuivre d'un
point de vue de l'intérêt général je
n'ai pas l'ordre absolu comme viennent
le présenter nos collègues du
rassemblement national mais bien le
principe de sûreté qui vient bien
au-delà de celui de sécurité qui a un
principe qui est dans la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et qui
dit qu'à la fois nous devons pouvoir
bénéficier de la sécurité matérielle pas
être inquiété pas de cambriolé pas se
faire voler etc certes mais d'avoir
aussi un principe de sécurité vis-à-vis
de la puissance publique de ne pas être
inquiété arbitrairement et ce principe
de sûreté il doit irriguer notre notre
pensée et on doit toujours l'avoir en
tête parce que c'est ça qui fait que
nous sommes dans une démocratie une
république et une république je l'espère
social
pour vous dire aussi que
si on devait faire des slogans pour
remettre les choses dans l'ordre il
faudrait dire que la liberté et la
première des sécurités si on voulait
remettre les choses à l'endroit ou dit
autrement la première des sécurités
c'est la sécurité sociale une fois ces
choses-là actées et dites on peut
ensuite examiner quel police nous
voulons qu'elle ministère de l'Intérieur
nous voulons puisque le texte est plus
large que juste les questions de
sécurité ou de sécurité civile au final
la question est de savoir quel service
public nous voulons au service des
citoyens et non pas des ambitions
présidentielles peut-être de Gérald
Darmanin
maintenant observons la question des
milliards il pleut des milliards sur le
ministère de l'Intérieur et c'était
assez intéressant de voir que quand on a
décortiqué la somme de 15 milliards
c'est compliqué de savoir ce qu'il y
avait dedans
j'ai même l'impression qu'on a d'abord
donné 15 milliards et ensuite on s'est
dit tiens qu'est-ce qu'on va bien
pouvoir en faire comme si vous aviez
demandé à la cantonnade comme ça une
somme et vous l'aviez obtenue bon alors
j'imagine qu'on finira par avoir le
détail les sénateurs ne l'ont pas eu
pour l'examen au Sénat puisqu'on vient
juste de la voir ce détail à l'Assemblée
nationale en tout cas si j'en crois les
dire de monsieur le rapporteur qui est
sur le sur le sur le sujet alors il
faudra regarder dans ces 15 milliards
qu'est-ce qu'on va garder qu'est-ce qui
est utile du point de vue de la sûreté
qu'est-ce qui est utile du point de vue
du service public et des objectifs qu'on
doit poursuivre bon par exemple le
réseau radio du futur je pense que
personne va trop s'y opposer bon très
bien par contre si c'est pour avoir des
des gendarmes mobiles supplémentaires
des CRS supplémentaires on pourrait dire
pourquoi pas mais si c'est pour les
envoyer à Sainte-Soline
pour fracasser les manifestants voir des
élus de la République c'est c'est un peu
problématique si c'est des milliards
pour faire mettre en place une police de
proximité on pourrait en discuter on
pourrait se dire tiens voilà une bonne
idée il faut effectivement avoir cet
objectif politique mais non ce n'est pas
ça l'objectif c'est de mettre 30 % de
bleu en plus sur le terrain en étant en
poursuivant la militarisation des
services de police dans leur équipement
dans leur façon d'être dans leur façon
de paraître ce qui est plutôt quelque
chose qui va vers l'escalade et
d'ailleurs vous voulez finalement d'une
police de plus en plus répressive et qui
puisse se passer en partie de la justice
parce que vous poursuivez à la cantonade
ce qui avait été dit si à côté de
l'Assemblée nationale par les
organisations policières en disant que
le problème de la police était la
justice et vous le traduisez en disant
laissons les policiers faire des amendes
forfaitaire délictuelles en étant juge
et partis en pouvant faire de la
répression immédiatement dans la rue
sans passer par la case autorité
judiciaire et l'investigation puisqu'il
ne me reste plus que qu'une trentaine de
secondes effectivement nous avions
défendu par exemple en la campagne
présidentielle qu'il fallait moins de
bacs plus de PJ pour un peu schématiser
que tout le monde comprenne quel est
l'objectif politique oui si nous voulons
atteindre la sûreté alors c'est la
police judiciaire qui doit être en
priorité dans les moyens et les
objectifs qu'on s'assigne en matière de
de justice et de judiciaire or ce n'est
pas ce que vous faites avec cette
départementalisation mais on y reviendra
pendant le débat et je terminerai en
disant que sur la déontologie policière
il a essayé une grosse carence énorme
dans les objectifs de rapprochement
police population il faut supprimer
l'IGPN et l'iggn dans leur capacité à
sanctionner individuelle
la parole est à Monsieur indépendant
merci monsieur le président
ce texte est naturellement opportun et
bienvenue je dirais enfin en fin car
nous avons et vous avez surtout perdu 5
ans au service de la sécurité des
Français se délai ce n'est pas moi qui
le souligne c'est un de vos
prédécesseurs le Premier ministre de
l'Intérieur de Monsieur Macron Gérard
Collomb qui la semaine dernière précisé
qu'on a juste perdu 5 ans en matière de
sécurité et d'immigration il a raison
les ambitions de ce texte paraissent
élevés mais au fond elles sont relatives
et parcellaires relatif parce que 15
milliards d'euros dont l'affectation
annuelle n'est pas précisée avec une
inflation qui va tangenter les 10%
laisseront finalement très peu de moyens
lorsqu'on sait que à peu près la moitié
seront réservés bien sûr à la lutte
contre la cybercriminalité c'est
important mais à la modernisation
l'outil informatique qui aujourd'hui en
a bien besoin ça veut dire sur un
fonctionnement quotidien du ministère et
pas au service des forces de sécurité je
veux souligner également qu'il y a des
carences très fortes dans ce texte
j'avais pour ma part il y a plusieurs
années souhaité la mise en place d'une
loi d'orientation et de programmation
sur la sécurité intérieure et la justice
or dans ce dans votre loi de
programmation il n'y a ni la justice ni
l'immigration ou de façon très
parcellaire c'est une lacune c'est un
défaut l'absence de voler justice va
priver d'une grande partie de la réponse
qu'attendent nos concitoyens à
l'augmentation de la violence de la
délinquance de la criminalité dans nos
rues avec l'apparition de zone de
non-droit de plus en plus fréquente je
regrette que il n'y a rien
sur les peines planchers qui devraient
protéger l'uniforme de la République et
je le dis c'est peine plancher aurait
été bien utile face aux extrémistes de
scène solide et qui ont provoqué des
violences extrêmement graves et vous
avez eu raison de parler
d'éco-terrorisme c'est peine plancher
c'est peine plancher aurait été
nécessaire face à ces hors de sauvage
qui ont attaqué les gendarmes je veux
également souligner que il n'y a rien
sur les interdictions de territoire
français sur la double peine alors que
vous avez fait opportunément le lien et
c'est nouveau et vous avez eu raison je
vous en félicite le lien entre
délinquance et immigration
délinquance et immigration que l'ancien
préfet l'allemand évoqué comme le
premier moyen d'intégration des
étrangers aujourd'hui donc nous
essaierons de compléter ce texte et
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir
souligné que nous un amendement pour
augmenter le nombre de placements dans
en cran sans de rétention parce que nous
considérons que c'est la seule procédure
qui permettra d'améliorer le taux
d'exécution des au qtf et de faire en
sorte que ceux qui sont rentrés
illégalement sur le territoire national
qui a fortiori ont commis des délits ou
des crimes n'est aucune raison de si
maintenir si on n'a pas la volonté de
revenir sur la procédure de placement
CRA on y arrivera pas donc merci d'avoir
répondu favorablement en tout cas nous y
travaillerons d'ici la séance sur cette
question je terminerai en disant que
votre réponse sur l'investigation ne
nous convaincue pas et les mises en
cause aujourd'hui et les réformes de la
police judiciaire inquiète beaucoup sur
les risques de déstabilisation de la
filière je considère pour ma part qu'il
ne faut pas toucher au Brigades du Tigre
qu'il ne faut pas toucher à la police
judiciaire et que votre réforme en la
matière est dangereuse nous en
débattrons dans un esprit constructif au
service de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens qui aujourd'hui en a bien
besoin madame Blandine brocard pour le
groupe démocrate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier mon groupe de
m'avoir confié la responsabilité de
porter ce texte parce que bien comme
vous comme le groupe démocrate je suis
profondément attaché aux forces de
sécurité intérieure alors mission et à
la nécessité qu'elle dispose des moyens
humains et technologiques pour les
remplir
après des années détricotage le
précédent quinquennat a vu un effort
sans précédent avec notamment le
renouvellement d'une partie du parc
automobile et c'est très apprécié sur le
terrain par nos forces de l'ordre pour
faciliter leur mission du continent et
le renouvellement de et la rénovation
pardon de l'immobilier ils en avaient
grand besoin mais il reste beaucoup pas
faire nous sommes tous régulièrement
interpellés par nos forces de l'ordre
sur ces difficultés qu'elle rencontre
même si de nets améliorations se font
nettement ressentir je salue d'ailleurs
particulièrement sens la proposition des
sénateurs de consacrer 300 millions
d'euros chaque année à l'immobilier de
la gendarmerie et je pense
particulièrement à la caserne de
Neuville-sur-Saône qui en a bien besoin
200 millions pour la reconstruction et
la réhabilitation des casernes et 100
millions pour leur entretien
je sais que dans toutes les brigades de
France une forte attention sera portée
au débat que nous aurons et j'espère
nous échanges toujours respectueux du
métier et de l'engagement des hommes et
des femmes qui agissent pour la sécurité
de nos concitoyens avec un sens de la
nuance c'est des débats qui semblent
déjà échapper à certains ici nos forces
de l'ordre méritent bien mieux que
certaines outrances elles veulent les
moyens d'exercer correctement et
sereinement leur mission au service de
nos concitoyens et cette loi de
programmation traduit en effet en
chiffres la considération de la
République pour celles et ceux qui la
protègent parfois au mépris de leur vie
c'est aussi un moteur qui je l'espère
fera naître des vocations pour servir
dans une police une gendarmerie moderne
efficace et plus présente auprès de nos
concitoyens
alors certains collègues monsieur le
ministre auront à l'occasion de vous
exprimer leurs interrogations en ce qui
concerne la réforme de la police
judiciaire en particulier si c'est
hésitations ne sont pas partagées par le
groupe démocrate je ne doute cependant
pas que vous saurez les rassurer ainsi
que nos policiers nous avons d'ailleurs
souhaité inscrire dans le rapport annexé
les critères de mise en œuvre de la
réforme de la police judiciaire parce
que nous savons qu'elle suscite en effet
des inquiétudes mais nous sommes
convaincus qu'elle est nécessaire
le groupe démocrate vous proposera tout
à l'heure un certain nombre
d'améliorations de ce projet de loi en
particulier deux amendements de
suppression nous aurons l'occasion dans
discuter davantage nous serons vigilants
à ce que c'est dispositions soient
traduites dans les lois budgétaires des
prochaines années également une dernière
chose je tiens aussi à remercier à
préciser l'excellent travail de
co-construction qui a été fait en amont
entre les groupes parlementaires et avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur je vous
remercie
merci monsieur Roger Vicot pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues donc ce texte
apporte un certain nombre d'avancer
incontestable notamment des avancées
budgétaires 15 milliards dont 8
milliards vous l'avez dit c'est-à-dire
un peu plus de la moitié pour ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la modernisation de la
police à travers l'informatique la
digitalisation l'immobilier tout ça
effectivement quelque chose dont on ne
peut contester l'avancée l'avancée
également avec le doublement annoncé des
effectifs sur le terrain d'ici 2030 même
s'il nous restons circonspect quant à la
faisabilité de ceci d'autant plus que je
rappelle que le Conseil d'État avait
indiqué que la crédibilité budgétaire
était affecté de nombreuses incertitudes
donc nous attendons si j'ose dire de
voir comment cette promesse certes
intéressante se concrétisera sur le
terrain il n'en demeure pas moins que ce
texte se laisse un certain nombre
d'interrogations alors la première ça a
été évoqué par plusieurs orateurs avant
moi c'est évidemment la réforme de la
police judiciaire monsieur le ministre
je vous demande peut-être davantage à
l'écoute d'une des nombreuses
interlocuteurs qui s'expriment sur ce
sujet et pas seulement les policiers
vous avez vu que la Conférence nationale
des procureurs généraux que les
procureurs de la République que l'Union
Syndicale des Magistrats que les
syndicats d'avocats se sont tous
exprimés sur les incertitudes et même
parfois les dangers qui sont générés par
cette par cette réforme
certaines grandes voix se sont également
exprimées je pense au Procureur Général
près la colocation François Molins qui a
affirmé clairement lui qui pourtant
d'habitude plutôt prudent que cette
réforme était porteuse d'un certain
nombre de dangers le procureur de la
République le vice-président du tribunal
de Melun qui explique que cette réforme
renforce considérablement le risque de
voir se développer une une
vacances de type mafieux pardon
excusez-moi et je ferme la je ferme les
guillemets et puis je note aussi que les
expérimentations dans un certain nombre
de départements n'ont pas été porteuses
de nombreuses louanges notamment parce
que parfois la prise en compte des
orientations politiques pénales du
ministère public n'ont pas été prises en
compte dans la manière dont cette
réforme est appliquée dans les
départements d'expérimentation
sur les recrutements certes nombreux qui
sont annoncés nous pensons qu'il y a
derrière ça une problématique de
formation à la fois de manière
quantitative mais aussi de manière
qualitative je pense aussi par exemple
aux assistants d'enquête et de la
manière dont leur formation va être
menée au regard des missions qui vont
être amenées à mettre en place sur les
amendes forfaitaire des rituels il nous
semble là aussi que même si cercle les
choses sont présentées comme une une
facilité supplémentaire mais qui a la à
risque aussi Hugo Bernal ici il évoqué
d'arbitraire mais que ça nous pose aussi
des questions de fond regardez droit des
victimes potentielles lorsqu'il y a
victime qui sont directement concernés
sur les plaintes en ligne là il s'agit
d'un amendement que nous aurons
l'occasion de défendre mais sur lequel
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs
parce qu'ils nous semble que la plainte
en ligne devrait être davantage
encadré dans un certain nombre de cas
notamment notamment lorsqu'il y a des
victimes directes de un trafic médial de
violence conjugales parce que la plante
en ligne n'est pas toujours la solution
idoine adéquate humainement monsieur
munize pour un certain nombre de cas et
qui nous semble que dans bien des cas
comme cela et bien les victimes devaient
être reçus directement humainement en
face à face au commissariat pour pouvoir
s'expliquer et que la plate en ligne
devrait être réservée aux victimes qui
le demandent c'est possible également
dans un certain nombre de cas et puis
monsieur le ministre très rapidement
j'aurais aimé avoir la ville
gouvernement sur l'amendement créant une
expérimentation de juridiction
spécialisée pour les violences
conjugales et sexuelles merci sachant
qu'il a été chers collègues déclaré
irrecevable puisque relevant des états
généraux de la justice Monsieur Philippe
Pradal pour le groupe horizon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues je tiens en premier à
remercier Monsieur Florent Boudier
rapporteur de ce texte pour la qualité
des échanges que nous avons pu avoir en
amont de cette séance au nom du groupe
horizon je tiens à souligner que la loi
d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la période
2022 2027 porte une ambition forte les
grandes priorités qui sont dégagent nous
sommes à la hauteur des enjeux en
premier lieu celui de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens en second lieu la
simplification et l'amélioration du
quotidien des agents du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui doit se poursuivre et je
m'associe aux hommages que vous leur
rendez régulièrement le renforcement des
moyens est doublement de la présence
policière sur le terrain avec 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur 5
ans 8500 créations de poste et 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
notamment doivent être soulignés c'est
un effort inédit est tellement
nécessaire le groupe horizon tient à
saluer la tension particulière portée au
territoire ruraux et périurbain qui lors
des quinquennat précédent ont pu
souffrir d'un recul de la présence de
l'État
nous souhaitons que cette proximité que
cette relation forte entre le ministère
de l'Intérieur et les collectivités
territoriales notamment les communes
soient explicitées accentués dans le
rapport annexé rappelons que la police
municipale est souvent primo arrivante
voire prix moins intervenantes auprès de
la population c'est l'esprit d'un
certain nombre d'amendements que nous
avons déposé cette proximité renforcée
avec le terrain sur un notamment permise
par la transition numérique majeure que
ministère souhaite engager en effet
cette modernisation des outils à
disposition des agents ayant profit
d'une efficacité accrue dans le rapport
aux usagers est un angle fort du projet
exposé dans le rapport annexé traduit
dans la loi les policiers gendarmes
seront plus nomades grâce aux tablettes
néo-entre autres en outre le réseau
radio du futur devrait être en capacité
d'offrir un système de communication au
débit sécurisé résilient et pleinement
interopérable au service de sécurité et
de secours et nous l'espérons aux
équipements de police municipale
moderniser c'est aussi mieux armée la
France et sa police face aux nouvelles
menaces les cyberattaques mettent de
nombreux établissements publics et
privés dans des situations de
vulnérabilité extrême je notamment aux
hôpitaux qui sont trop régulièrement
touchés par ces attaques outre les
moyens à disposition des enquêteurs le
groupe horizon souhaite que la réponse
de la justice soit extrêmement ferme il
est intolérable que la vie des patients
puissent être mis en danger la loi doit
être particulièrement dissuasive à les
garder réseau criminels qui alimentent
cette menace enfin le groupe Horizon est
totalement d'accord avec la politique de
renforcement de l'attractivité du métier
de policier grâce notamment à
l'allègement des tâches administratives
des agents de police à cet effet la
création des assistants d'enquêtes
recrutés au sein des personnels
administratifs du ministères permettant
de prendre en charge un certain nombre
de tâches mais également de créer
probablement des vocations pour le
métier d'enquêteur le nombre d'agents de
terrain va donc considérablement
augmenter sur les prochaines années
notamment vu de l'organisation des
événements comme les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 un certain nombre
de dispositions de la loopmie posent les
jalons d'une future loi consacrée à ce
sujet nous semblerait néanmoins
intéressants de savoir d'ores et déjà la
ventilation des crédits qui sont
consacrés à la sécurisation des jeux et
des grands événements sportifs en effet
il y aura un enjeu sécuritaire majeur et
la regarder de près par le monde entier
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quel montant du budget privé
article 2 de la locmi sera consacré aux
événements sportifs à venir et quel
serait la répartition à ce stade de
votre réflexion entre les forces de
police et gendarmerie et les organismes
de sécurité privée merci merci Madame
pour le groupe écologiste
des visions différentes et c'est bien
logique mais nous partageons au moins de
ceci une volonté une aspiration
républicaine a poussé à l'amélioration
de la sécurité pour nos concitoyens et
concitoyens et ça passe par le soutien
et la transformation de l'organisation
de nos forces de l'ordre et de sécurité
civile c'est bien logique c'est le
devoir de l'État que de pourvoir à la
sécurité à égalité à travers tous les
territoires de ses concitoyens et donc
d'assurer un service au service du
public vous nous avez dit en
introduction monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques minutes donc entamiez ce
travail avec nous dans un esprit
d'ouverture et je m'en réjouis je m'en
réjouis d'autant plus que jusqu'à
présent il était assez regrettable que
les discours portent beaucoup sur la
question de dialoguer de construire
ensemble et que vous exprimiez à
plusieurs reprises ici notamment le
refus de tout dialogue concret tout
dialogue dans l'expression parlementaire
avec les oppositions les discours et les
actes peuvent connaître de micro
différents c'est évidemment mais quand
il s'opposent ils abîment aussi bien
notre fonction que notre mission
et ce qui m'ennuyait jusqu'à présent
mais je vous prends en mode donc je
crois que nous allons le changer c'est
que ce refuge s'est traduit surtout par
du mépris encore une fois dans cette
commission d'un hémicycle notamment pour
reposer et choisir entre les gauches et
les écologistes suivants qu'ils soient
des bons ou des mauvais élèves selon
vous un mépris pour ce que porte
globalement les écologistes leur valeur
et leur combat surtout comme il y a
quelques jours sur les événements de
sainte Soline où vous n'avez pas hésité
à assimiler sans distinction tous les
écologistes à des terroristes
l'assimilation dangereuse vous le savez
je suis certaine monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur que vous le savez que le
terrorisme ce n'est pas ce que nous
incarnons ici
et j'en veux pour preuve du risque qu'il
y a les Outrans que mon collègue fiotit
vient de commettre à l'instant à notre
rencontre n'est pas normal que ces
propos là puissent avoir lieu au sein de
nous
institutions alors que les élus de la
République des représentants du peuple
ce sont effectivement fait molestés par
des forces de l'ordre sur ordre et dans
l'exercice de fonction vous n'avez pas
eu ni mes collègues ni vous monsieur le
ministre en seul mot pour nos collègues
Lisa bellucco et Benoît Biteau
mais parce qu'il y a un objectif
important à renforcer notre sécurité à
porter la réorganisation de notre vie
c'est de la gendarmerie de l'être et là
mais questionnements et je vous invite
et je nous invite à ne pas nous perdre
dans les investis personnels et avancer
sur le fond je mise donc sur vos propos
et la volonté de dialogue affiché que
monsieur le rapporteur et monsieur le
Président vous saurez mettre en oeuvre
et serait dommage quand même que nous
nous braquions collectivement au moment
où de gros textes importants pour la
France profil et les 49-3 commencent à
se raréfier cette lobby nous propose
donc d'améliorer les conditions de
travail et d'organisation de nos forces
de l'ordre et nous partageons cet
objectif modulons en détail notre
attention se porte en premier lieu sur
l'efficacité réelle du service au public
et c'est là que le bât blesse et donc je
ferai en trois exemples en une minute
vous nous dites un qu'il est nécessaire
de rapprocher les forces de l'ordre et
de la population ne renforcer les liens
de la confiance et le dialogue nous
sommes d'accord
mais j'ai du mal à saisir comment est-ce
que mettre des robots mettre des
exosquelettes pour rassurer la
population et rapprocher et créer du
dialogue je vous rappelle l'objectif
c'est l'efficacité vous voulez également
une police qui aille mieux et qui
travaille mieux mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment minorer le travail
dans l'enquête sur le terrain peut
conduire à ça après les manifs des flics
en colère après la colère frotte de la
PJ je crois que ce n'est décemment pas
la bonne chose à suivre et enfin vous
les répondre à la nécessaire demande de
cesser de perdre de perdre du temps des
agents sur le terrain par des AFD mais
mes collègues ont commencé à vous le
dire retirer la justice n'est jamais une
avancée il me reste 15 secondes je les
prends et elle traduisent aussi et
surtout une forme de managérialisation
pardon pour le néogisme de notre
organisation qui prive le terrain et qui
renforce les élites je ne pense pas non
plus que ce soit votre dessin important
c'est la réalité bref un service au
service du public c'est ce que nous
défendrons j'espère que nous vous sur ce
combat monsieur le ministre madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le lien a jug
é sur la faveur des arbitrages obtenus à
Bercy il nous suffirait de dire que vous
avez obtenu bien plus que les autres
ministères et il y a des ministères sur
lesquels nous aurions aimé aussi des
augmentations aussi conséquentes mais
évidemment on ne se prononce pas que sur
une masse on se prononce aussi sur une
trajectoire sur des objectifs sur un
sens je m'en tiendrai ici à nos
principaux à la fois pointes des accords
et nos propositions alors je vous avoue
que j'ai entendu ce matin votre
ouverture
je vous crois a priori mais
permettez-moi forcément de douter
vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe ces
derniers temps des appels à la
co-construction pour finalement arriver
à des 49-3 et des méthodes brutales mais
tenons-nous-en à votre engagement de ce
matin je reviens sur l'idée que nous
jugeons ici des choix budgétaires opérés
dans cette loop me force et de constater
qu'elle s'aligne sur des mesures
issues de la loi sécurité globale vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'on s'y est
largement opposé elle s'appuie aussi sur
des revendications de certains
syndicat policiers qui ont scandé il y a
quelques temps devant notre assemblée
que le problème de la police serait la
justice pareil c'est quelque chose que
nous combattons résolument par ailleurs
vous proposez de renforcer la vidéo
surveillance les caméras piétons les
policiers robots les frontières
connectées ces équipements dit de pointe
ne remplaceront jamais une présence
humaine de proximité en tout cas selon
nous et vos choix vu budgétaires se font
malheureusement au détriment de moyens
mis à la fois pour la proximité mais
aussi pour les investigations les
filatures les enquêtes c'est déterminant
si nous voulons assurer la sûreté ils se
font aussi au détriment de meilleures
conditions de travail pour pour les
agents de police je pense ici par
exemple à l'alinéa 134 du rapport annexé
qui entend privilégié la compensation
financeur des heures supplémentaires
plutôt que le choix quand il s'agit de
choisir entre
heures supplémentaires ou forme de
récupération
je on l'a dit d'autres l'ont dit en plus
cette troc la police judiciaire pour une
police augmentée qui ne permettra en
rien l'efficacité c'est à dire le choix
de protéger les citoyens autre point qui
nous semble crucial c'est la relation
police citoyen vous aviez annoncé que
c'était une des ambitions de ce texte
force de constater en regardant le point
de point 6 du rapport annexé sur ce
sujet c'est très flou mais aussi très
stigmatisant vous confondez délinquance
juvénile quartier politique de la ville
usant d'expression aussi peu précises
que jeunes de quartier rien n'est dit
rien n'est fait concrètement pour
améliorer améliorer les rapports
populaires police population à part
proposer à des jeunes de 11 ans d'aller
faire des stages dans la police la
confiance ça se décrète pas elle se
gagne et je crois qu'un des leviers
majeurs au cœur de ce défi c'est
l'égalité de traitement entre tous les
citoyens nous reviendrons donc au
travers d'un amendement pour la mise en
place du récépissé de contrôle
d'identité afin de lutter contre les
contrôles discriminants et le
déploiement aussi d'une police de
proximité les habitants et habitants de
des quartiers populaires ont le droit à
la sûreté il la demande il dénonce des
sensibilités et ils exigent en même
temps un traitement digne et respectueux
leurs droits fondamentaux rien de plus
rien de moi améliorer le rapporte police
population c'est également condamner les
policiers quand ils sont coupables de
violence l'exemplarité c'est une donnée
primordiale du rapport de confiance à ce
titre nous continuons de penser que
l'IGPN doit être refondé pour une
autorité véritablement indépendante par
ailleurs nulle part dans vos éléments de
langage les 16 articles du projet de loi
les 88 pages du rapport annexés
n'apparaissent ne serait-ce qu'un début
de réflexion sur la doctrine du maintien
de l'ordre en France et cela malgré la
gestion désastreuse de la séquence gilet
jaune le maintien d'or doit permettre
l'exercice des libertés publiques elle
nécessite un strict équilibre entre
liberté et maintes et ordre public
moi quand je vois sainte Soline
effectivement je m'inquiète de votre
terme je le condamne parce que je crois
qu'il non je crois qu'il fait violence
aussi aux victimes des
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Sequoia pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues face aux attentes
toujours plus fortes des populations
vis-à-vis de la sécurité il était
nécessaire que l'État accorde enfin un
soutien budgétaire et matériel à la
hauteur des enjeux en ce sens il paraît
effectivement nécessaire de redonner à
l'ensemble des acteurs de la sécurité et
des secours une capacité d'action une
capacité d'action renforcée certes mais
sans excès c'est pourquoi je m'exprime
aujourd'hui au nom de du groupe liotte
qui souhaitent salut les objectifs
budgétaires ambitieux même s'ils devront
être confirmés au cours de la
législature on ne peut nier l'effort en
termes de moyens avec une hausse cumulée
sur cinq ans de 15 milliards d'euros
notre groupe constate que cette
trajectoire est respectée pour cette
première marge 2023 avec un budget
sécurité qui dépasse les 22 milliards
d'euros nous rejoignons cependant les
critiques du Conseil d'État sur les
failles du rapport annexés les objectifs
sont listés de manière épars sans
hiérarchisation et il y a une absence
presque systématique de corrélation
entre moyens et objectifs notre groupe
regrette également que le calendrier est
déjà conduite à un examen de la mission
sécurité avant d'avoir débattu et des
priorités d'autre part nous suivrons
avec attention évidemment le retour
annoncé dans les territoires des 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie nous
appelons néanmoins une concertation
réelle pour rétablir le lien avec les
élus locaux et territoriaux se
déploiement doit se faire en partenariat
avec les collectivités de quelle marge
de manoeuvre vous disposez les élus
notamment les maires dans leurs échanges
avec les préfets l'efficacité des
actions dépend donc intrinsèquement de
la densité du maillage territorial et de
la capacité d'adaptation des brigades
c'est pourquoi notre groupe souhaite
obtenir des éclaircissements
concrètement quelle répartition pour ces
nouvelles brigades entre collectivités
venons-en aussi à présent aux réformes
liées à la police judiciaire qui ont
suscité de vivre et actions
notre compatir la tension du
gouvernement sur la nécessité de
garantir la spécificité de la PJ alors
que l'étude d'impact évoque un besoin de
5000 OPJ dès 2023 en plus de 17000 ayant
déjà cette qualité les mesures portées
par ce projet de loi semblent toujours
insuffisantes nous relevons la volonté
de former tous de former tous les
nouveaux policiers gendarmes en fonction
d'objet de la fonction de la formation
initiale mais cette seule mesure ne
permettra pas de répondre au manque à
court terme il faudra des formateurs et
réviser les programmes dans la laps de
temps restreint pour susciter des
vocations les députés de notre groupe
n'ont pas de réticence outre mesure
vis-à-vis de la création des assistants
d'enquête au contraire c'est greffiers
de police qui devrait permettre
d'alléger la charge procédure à les
enquêteurs pour leur permettre de se
concentrer sur leur cœur de métier
cependant certains points de vente
clarifiés en particulier la prochaine
réforme de la PJ sur le terrain les
enquêteurs redoutent fortement d'être
placé sur l'autorité d'un directeur
départemental de la police nationale
créant de se voir entraver dans la
conduite de leurs investigations et de
ne plus pouvoir assurer leur mission
avec toute l'indépendance nécessaire
comme vous le savez cela même suscité
des craintes par des collectifs
antimaphia encore de voir la PJ être
diminué dans ses missions concernant le
grand banditisme sur la question de ce
que vous appelez les nouvelles menaces
les députés lyotes prennent note de la
possibilité de saisir la crypto actif
qui nous paraît être une bonne mesure
par ailleurs et comme vous pouvez en
douter je suis réservé sur la
probléative renforcée que vous souhaitez
accorder au préfet de départements sur
les services de l'État en cas de crise
pour cela il y a des états d'urgence qui
sont des régimes d'exception et qui ne
doivent en aucun cas glisser vers le
droit commun
notre groupe à l'ADN très
décentralisateur l'efficacité le situe
pas pour nous dans le renforcement des
prérogatives des préfets mais bien dans
le partage et la croissance des
compétences et responsabilités des
collectivités qui selon nous sur le
mieux à même de paliers difficultés
rencontrées par leur territoire enfin
nous nous opposons pas aux nombreuses
améliorations apportées par les
sénateurs au texte qui ont permis de
corriger les principales failles comme
le choix qui a été opéré par les
rapporteurs du Sénat de déployer de
manière plus restrictive l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle le technicien
allait beaucoup trop vite et aurait
concerné donc 3400 infraction par
ailleurs nous tenons à souligner
l'introduction dans le texte du plus
forte répression des agressions contre
les élus locaux les chiffres 2021
parlent de même plus de 160
parlementaires et plus de 600 élus
municipaux agressés soignent de 47% en
un an il était nécessaire d'améliorer la
réponse pénale sur ce point je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole pour répondre aux orateurs du
groupe
merci monsieur le Président bon d'abord
je voudrais de nouveau salut le travail
de monsieur le rapporteur lui dire qu'on
serait évidemment attentif
aux modifications qui se fait apporter
au texte et comme je l'ai dit un avis
favorable à C6 70 amendements et on aura
l'occasion sans doute de revenir
en séance si on ne le fait pas en
commission sur les interrogations qui
l'a évoqué ici ou là peut-être dire à
chacune et à chacun d'abord de vous
remercier de reconnaître qu'une
augmentation sans précédent des crédits
du ministère de l'intérieur après je
comprends bien que la question c'est à
quoi ça sert et comment on s'en occupe
mais c'est la première fois me
semble-t-il qu'on peut trouver
uneanimité sur le fait que d'abord on a
une programmation je veux dire monsieur
bernadisse que je suis tout à fait prêt
à la détailler il y a pas de ce genre
soir après l'avenir est toujours fait
d'incertitude c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait logique mais oui on peut on
peut les détailler bien davantage que
nous faisons aujourd'hui s'impose aucun
problème et j'en profite que Monsieur
Ciotti soit là pour lui dire que sa
critique sur l'inflation n'est on a eu
pas la bonne il connaît bien le budget
du ministère de l'Intérieur il sait que
à l'intérieur c'est quand même
essentiellement du T2 c'est-à-dire du
personnel et qu'à ce titre l'inflation
ne touche pas sur le budget du personnel
puisque ce qui augmente ses prix du
matériel et le prix du matériel par
nature ce ne sont pas des femmes et des
hommes donc si jamais il y avait un
impact j'ai expliqué à la fois à vos
collègues du rassemblement national qui
me posait à peu près la même question
pour dévaloriser un peu en tout cas pour
poser la question des moyens réels
donnés pour le ministère de l'Intérieur
si jamais cette inflation devait manger
autant le budget que vous l'évoquez ce
serait pas juste dans le ministère de
l'Intérieur puisque encore une fois
l'essentiel du budget c'est du personnel
donc on n'applique pas l'inflation au
personnel dans le rt2 il s'agit vous
voyez par exemple de moyens qui ont déjà
vu signer un certain nombre de contrats
je prends l'exemple du réseau radio du
futur les plus de 2 milliards d'euros
bloquer ont été signés et lancés avant
les augmentations d'inflation donc si je
prends l'exemple très concret de combien
nous coûte l'inflation en imaginant
qu'elle soit un chiffre très élevé tout
le long de l'année 2023 voilà je prends
vraiment l'hypothèse la plus définitive
sur un milliard de 150 millions d'euros
de crédit on parlait de crédit
supplémentaire ce n'est que 210 millions
d'euros donc je pense qu'il peut pas
dire que c'est un budget qui en fait ne
correspond pas à une augmentation on
voit bien que je crois que beaucoup de
gens l'ont signé c'est une augmentation
réelle d'ailleurs faudrait chacun de ces
ici partir du principe que il n'y aurait
pas de PLFR sur l'inflation à la fin
d'un exercice budgétaire ce qui serait
d'ailleurs sans doute un délicat vous
allez vous même je crois que ce matin
quand on s'est mis c'est un bel effet
qui est présenté que vous allez discuter
donc il y a toujours d'ailleurs des fins
de gestion qui permettent d'être au
rendez-vous des causes extérieures donc
je pense qu'il faut pas bouder son
plaisir mais pouvoir bien souligner le
fait que cette augmentation s'en passe
là ce qui me permet de dire aussi du
rassemblement national qui me permettent
comme être une erreur sur la
revalorisation salariale il y a pas de
revalorisation salariale ce sera la plus
grande revalorisation salariale tous les
fonctionnaires de police de gendarmerie
de l'histoire du ministère de
l'Intérieur en 5 ans c'est un 13e mois
que nous leur reversons si vous regardez
notamment le la consécration budgétaire
de ce que j'ai signé avec l'unanimité
des syndicats de police et l'ensemble
des organisations présentatives de la
gendarmerie nationale ça n'a jamais
existé à l'intérieur sur une convention
sociale l'unanimité c'est une
augmentation de tous y compris et en
premier lieu des gardiens de la paix et
des gendarmes des brigades territoriales
c'est 100 euros de plus par mois et des
cette année on a même pas attendu la
locmi puisque nous avons commencé à
débloquer un certain nombre d'argent
nous avons nous allons tripler la prime
de de des policiers de la nuit je
rappelle que c'est moi qui l'ai créé
cette prime avant n'existait pas il y
avait un syndicat je mets des guillemets
parce option lui qui avait été créé à
l'époque depuis ils ont salué le travail
qui avait fait demi à l'intérieur à
plusieurs reprises et on a triplé c'est
ce qu'on vous propose la prime de nuit
par exemple ici pour le première fois je
suis mise à l'intérieur qui accorde des
primes spécifiques au Cérès de montagne
au gendarme de PGHM il ne les avait pas
précédemment nous doublons la prime OPJ
ce qui n'existait pas précédemment on
pourrait faire le détail de toutes les
avancées sociales pour parler
comme Fabien Roussel les ouvriers de la
sécurité on est au rendez-vous de leur
demande sociale et donc là je pense que
quand vous dites que la revalorisation
salariale n'est pas au rendez-vous je
sais pas quand elle le sera puisque il
n'y a pas je crois de comparaison
possible dans les augmentations de
salaire vous aurez compris que j'étais
prise d'augmentation de salaire en
général on les applique au ministère de
l'Intérieur et c'est 100 points d'indice
on rajoutera ensuite effectivement le
point de vice qui touche tous les
fonctionnaires donc je pense que là vous
devriez quand même souligner cette
revalorisation salariale fonctionnaire
massive alors j'ai bien compris que vous
souhaitiez des questions sur la police
municipale mais j'ai compris que vous
souhaitiez deux choses j'ai donc compris
qu'il y avait à la fois le débat de
grande obligatoire la prise municipale
dans toutes les communes de France
depuis 10.000 habitants et deuxièmement
donner des moyens supplémentaires au
maire sur la police municipale alors le
premier point le problème c'est que ça
oui j'ai bien compris le premier point
malheureusement si j'ose dire ce
contre-car à l'article 72 de la
Constitution je ne peux pas forcer des
collectivités locales et vous non plus
d'ailleurs sauf à changer la
constitution et c'est un débat qui n'est
pas lieu ici qui a dit ailleurs et de
dire administration des collectivités
locales elles ont si elles le souhaitent
des polices municipales elle les armes
ou pas d'ailleurs la mairie de Paris a
voulu créer une police municipale nous
l'avons accompagné mais elle a pas voulu
l'armée bon on peut le regretter moi
Tourcoing et armée mais on le respecte
totalement l'article 72 effectivement de
la Constitution donc d'abord on ne peut
pas rendre obligatoire par la loi ce
serait raconté des guerres noisettes
comme on dit chez moi le fait qu'on
puisse rentrer dans une obligation des
polices municipales dans la vie depuis
10 000 habitants deuxièmement sur
l'extension des points de la police
municipale et du maire on a eu ce débat
très longuement avant que vous
n'arriviez ici mais Madame Le Pen
pourrait vous raconter sans doute ses
débats sur la loi de sécurité globale
que d'ailleurs vous avez voté donc ce
que dit cette fois sécurité globale elle
disait qu'on pouvait imaginer une
expérimentation de donner des pouvoirs
supplémentaires aux polices municipales
notamment qui sont parfois très
pratiques je le constate bien volontiers
ayant été maire moi-même simplement le
Conseil constitutionnel nous a dit deux
choses il nous a dit soit vous donnez
plus de moyens un peu explicital alors
les polices municipales dépendent du
procureur de la République c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce qui se passe
avec les policiers nationaux moi
j'embauche les policiers nationaux mais
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
répète sans cesse je n'emploie pas les
policiers nationaux dans les enquêtes et
dans les contrôles d'identité c'est pas
le mise intérieur qu'il le fait donc
soit vous le mettez à disposition du
procureur de la République soit vous
changez la Constitution puisque on peut
pas avoir de moyens
judiciaire pour les polices municipales
donc il faut que vous choisissiez si
vous voulez le combat si vous voulez
donner plus de moyens pour les polices
municipales si on change la Constitution
encore une fois c'est pas la loi
ordinaire qui peut le faire vous aurez
sans doute un débat sur une réforme
constitutionnelle qui arrivera dans le
quinquennat donc ça peut être l'occasion
d'en discuter vu qu'il y a pas de
cavaliers législatif pour la réforme
constitutionnelle monsieur le Président
soit on part du principe que les polices
municipales sont à la disposition des
procureurs de la République je suis pas
sûr qu'il y a un maire de France qui est
très envie de confier sa police
municipale à autre chose qu'à lui-même
donc je pense que c'est pas un bon
procès non plus on a été au maximum de
ce que nous pouvions faire sur
l'extension des pouvoirs de prix
festival j'aurais renseigner qu'à ce
sont des nerfs de France et elle-même
extrêmement
peu clair si je peux me permettre sur ce
qu'elle souhaite pour les polices
municipales entre la police municipale
de Nice et la police municipale de
Troyes entre la police municipale de
Perpignan et la police municipale de
Bordeaux de Strasbourg il y a un monde
et c'est normal c'est l'article qui
permet la diversification de position
unanime me semble-t-il des mères sur ce
sujet mais c'est évidemment une question
très importante alors Monsieur T comme
vous-même évoquez le fait qu'il était
c'est un texte si j'ai bien compris
important et bienvenue mais incomplet
vous regrettez l'absence de mesure
justice peine plancher etc je bon je ne
suis pas le garde des sceaux monsieur
Ciotti c'est très bien que lui-même pour
avoir été travaillé sur les dopsies il y
a jamais eu de textes polices justice
quand vous étiez en responsabilité
pourquoi pas innover mais enfin
l'innovation c'est pas toujours pour les
autres monsieur le monsieur le député se
dit je crois que votre curiosité et
votre faim et votre curiosité et votre
et votre fin de justice sera au
rendez-vous parce que je crois que le
garde des sceaux va bientôt présenter un
texte de politique pénale donc là vous
aurez l'occasion sans doute d'en
reparler avec lui et sur la textes
immigration je crois qu'on voit bien que
il arrive ça a été évoqué en allant
l'occasion d'avoir ce débat bien
évidemment après il faut savoir aussi je
dis président de la commission des lois
ce qu'on veut soit quand le gouvernement
avec des textes longs on dit il est trop
long on a pas le temps discuter quand il
arrive à des textes thématiques et il
est pas assez long bon donc c'est
peut-être tapenage de l'opposition
finalement de jamais de jamais d'accord
mais voilà on a fait on a fait je crois
assez large quand même nous parlerons
d'immigration et nous parlerons justice
immigration nous en parlerons ensemble
avec Olivier dussobe et justice vous en
parlerai avec monsieur le garde des
sceaux incessamment sous peu alors
Monsieur Bernal ici a évoqué bon ça
donne une différence on reviendra sans
doute je ferai une réponse globale sur
la réforme de la police nationale qui
n'est pas la réforme de la police
judiciaire qui est la réforme de la
police nationale on en reparlera juste
corrigé monsieur et ben ici vous avez
pas dit moins de bac plus de sécurité de
proximité vous vous avez dit suppression
de la BAC je vous rappelle voilà donc la
moindre risque pas le discours de
Monsieur Mélenchon qui était lui-même
extrêmement modéré c'était pas la peine
de de de
la moindre rire revenons revenons non
mais c'est marrant vous dites plus vous
dites plus suppression de bac
aujourd'hui ça peut
alors on corrigera vous-même dis-moi
dans une forme de dans une forme de
dans une forme dans une forme dans une
forme d'autorité d'un seul coup retrouvé
vous avez dit moins de bacs moi j'ai
compris que c'était finalement donc pas
de bac du tout
sur la question de Monsieur Vico sur la
plate en ligne moi je j'ai compris que
votre amendement était heureuse ça mais
j'ai trouvé que ma maman du rapporteur
pour préciser en effet que ça ne peut
être que la victime qui demande la
plainte en visio et jamais le service de
police gendarmerie qui lui impose je
pensais que c'était clair dans le débat
qu'on a vu avec les sénateurs et dans le
texte puisqu'il y a un doute je me
rongerai à la vie du rapporteur pour
bien préciser que c'est une modalité de
possibilités on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler qui est très pratique mais qui
n'est pas qui peut d'ailleurs permettre
les libération de la parole aussi mais
qui n'est pas la règle et on est bien
d'accord et c'est vraiment que la
victime donne son accord auquel le
demande soyez-en rassuré sur ce point
pour Monsieur Pradal oui alors j'ai eu
l'occasion de développer ça devant le
sén
les Jeux Olympiques avec le nom de rugby
mais je suis à l'exposition monsieur
présente mission des lois s'il le veut
sur ce sujet de particulier il y aura 45
000 forces de l'ordre tous les jours
concernés par les Jeux Olympiques voilà
donc et là j'ai eu l'occasion de
d'envoyer une instruction au préfet de
dire qu'on se fichait des zones de
police et gendarmerie pendant cette
période-ci et on doit m'utiliser
évidemment les moyens on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler c'est vraiment il n'y a
pas eu de d'équivalent alors évidemment
la locmi elle prévoit de tenir ses 45000
forces de l'ordre à l'instant T dans une
journée de des Jeux Olympiques la
recréation des zones unités de force
mobile y contribuent vous aurez
l'occasion d'ailleurs de voir que c'est
même 17 forces mobiles qu'on libère
puisque on libère notamment les gardes
statiques à Paris qui sont aujourd'hui
fait par des unités de force mobile
devant Bovo devant l'ambassade d'Israël
devant l'ambassade des États-Unis devant
l'Élysée pour les remplacer par des
policiers donc c'est la la le modèle la
responsabilité que de faire des gardes
statiques c'est pas tout à fait le
métier des mobiles qui par nature
doivent pas être statique puisqu'ils
sont mobiles bon donc ça libère quand
même beaucoup d'unités les récréations
des unités de brigade de gendarmerie
vont être utilisés en attendant la
récréation parce que nous créons des
gendarmes et des policiers en grand
nombre dans les deux premières années
budgétaires je voyais quand même
souligner je le dis aussi aux groupes
Front National qui dit mais il y a pas
de moyens supplémentaires dans les
premières années nous faisons 90% des
créations de poste dans les deux
premières années c'est la première fois
que le mystère intérieur va recruter
plus de 3000 personnes
chaque année dans les forces de l'ordre
ce qui est d'ailleurs un défi de
formation et d'organisation évidemment
très très important à tout ça va
contribuer à ces 45 000 on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que pour la sécurité
privée c'est plus d'un 5000 personnes
qu'il nous faudrait on en reparlera bien
évidemment je reviendrai pas sur le
l'intervention plus plus générale de
Madame rigole juste son intervention sur
les esosquelettes si vous lisez bien le
rapport annexé il s'agit surtout de la
sécurité civile et si vous êtes allé
voir des pompiers voir le Congrès des
sapeurs-pompiers vous démontre comment
devant les poids supplémentaires
désormais des moyens pour éteindre les
incendies devant aussi des maladies
professionnelles que connaissent ces sa
la réforme de la police nationale
députés elle n'est pas législative elle
est entièrement réglementaire
alors si je peux terminer ma phrase vous
allez voir ce dernier six je vais
essayer de mettre une pensée derrière
cette phrase je sais que c'est pas
évident à priori mais je m'améliore
chaque jour la preuve du pudding c'est
ce qui se mange est-ce que vous pensez
un seul instant que nous pourrions
toucher à la séparation des pouvoirs à
la relation avec l'autorité judiciaire
et au pouvoir des magistrats sans
changer un article de loi évidemment la
Constitution un article de loi bien sûr
que non le fait que nous puissions faire
la réforme d'un pays national qu'avec du
réglementaire et la démonstration même
que nous touchons à aucun article de la
cote de procédure pénale pardon de cette
autologie aucun article du code pénal
donc nous devons bien comprendre que la
réforme de police nationale c'est pour
ça qu'il n'y a aucun article de loi en
dur comme dirait les mauvais juristes
qui concernent la forme de police
nationale puisqu'elle est totalement
réglementaire
alors il y a malgré le fait qu'elle soit
totalement réglementaire d'abord une
honnêteté de la part du gouvernement
expliqué ce qu'il va faire dans les cinq
ans qui viennent deuxièmement une
volonté d'écouter toutes les questions
toutes les demandes toutes tes
préoccupations puisqu'il s'agit d'une
réforme qu'on fait à peu près tous les
siècles puisque la dernière qui a été
faite de cet envergure tout le monde
l'acide c'est celle de paiement a un peu
changé depuis que les morceaux on a
inventé internet il y a la technologie
il y a un certain nombre de
fonctionnement de la criminalité qui
n'est pas du tout la même mais je veux
bien comprendre qu'il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations une réforme qui a été
lancée à 36 ans par mon collègue Jobs
pardon de le dire comme ça évidemment
elle pose des questions c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que nous ne souhaitons pas nous
ne souhaitons pas aller de manière non
concertée il y a aujourd'hui monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
trois missions qui travaillent en même
temps une de votre assemblée c'est de
votre collègue givevoux et de votre
collègue bernadisse donc j'ai compris
qu'il est en train de leur rapport au
mois de janvier j'ai bien compris une du
Sénat pour un collègue monsieur Durand
pour le groupe social et de Madame
bellura pour le groupe LR et une
commandée par moi-même de l'inspection
générale de l'administration et j'ai
demandé je vous ai passé la copie de ce
courrier monsieur le Président et
Monsieur bernalicis également d'ailleurs
comme nous instruction générale la
justice pour que il puisse regarder
cette réforme qui a fait à la fois
couler de l'encre mais qui a aussi connu
des expérimentations donc on aura
l'occasion de regarder des
expérimentations dures l'outre-mer des
augmentations en sans changer les textes
en métropole bon donc d'abord on
attendra le retour de ces
expérimentations pour faire la réforme
ça c'est le premier point donc on attend
que Monsieur Bernal ici c'est même
givenou ramène son rapport on attendra
que Monsieur monsieur Durin et Madame
bellerault ramène le rapport avec les
inspection mettre le rapport et alors je
m'engage à ce que le rapport des
inspections soit communiqué est rendu
public Auchan premièrement deuxièmement
il y a des élections syndicales en ce
moment comme partout dans la fonction
publique donc on va attendre que les
syndicats soient relégitimés par le vote
des fonctionnaires et à partir du mois
de une fois qu'ils auront été élus nous
discuterons de cette réforme de la
police nationale qui concerne l'ensemble
de la police nationale une réforme
extrêmement importante je n'en
disconviens pas avec ces syndicats
nouvellement élus c'est tout à fait
logique que nous ne fassions et j'ai
déjà dit que nous ferions des des
modifications si nous devions évidemment
les faire troisièmement j'ai déjà dit au
Sénat et j'ai accepté un amendement qui
prévoyait la spécificité de la police
judiciaire pour bien qu'on comprenne
qu'il s'agit évidemment pas de supprimer
la préjudiciaire d'ailleurs nous ne
pourrions pas supprimer la préjudiciaire
sans article de loi donc comme on change
pas la loi encore une fois je veux
redire c'est évident mais j'ai proposé
au Sénat qui ne l'a pas accepté que nous
puissions encadrer la réforme de la
police nationale pour rassurer tout le
monde de tout ce que nous devons tous et
tous
il y aura-t-il le libre choix du service
de police ou de gendarmerie par le
magistrat et qu'il soit procureur la
réponse est oui l'article 12 du code de
procédure pénale ne changera pas donc
bien sûr il y a aucun problème pour le
répéter deux il y aura-t-il une police
judiciaire qui est dans chaque
département départementalisé j'ai déjà
dit que non je l'ai dit depuis le mois
de juillet nous garderons tous les
offices j'en ai même créé un devant vous
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois nous garderons toutes les
antennes et nous pourrions
imaginer que nous pourrions l'inscrire
effectivement dans le texte aucun
problème il ne s'agit pas de
départementaliser toute la police
judiciaire c'est une un sujet il y a des
moments où il faut mieux travailler
ensemble il y a des moments où
évidemment l'antenne régionale
l'antenzoane ou l'office ne fonctionne
bien et j'ai dit qu'on ne toucherait pas
cette cartographie bon troisièmement la
probité est-ce que le préfet instruit
par le service de police
départementalisés ainsi créé va
connaître toutes les informations et va
donc dès le début déjeuner avec telle ou
tel député ou tel ou tel de donner pour
lui donner toutes les informations qui
le concernent je rappelle d'ailleurs que
chacun a des directeurs départementaux
des finances publiques je suis pas sûr
qu'ils vous communique tous les
contrefiscaux auxquels vous êtes
octroyez-vous et vos amis mais en
imaginant que tout ce monde peut-être
dans un film de Chabrol se parlerait à
ce point que le soir entre deux dîner
chez le notaire on donne des
informations
j'entends l'argument et donc on a décidé
de dire que toutes les questions qui
relèvent de la délinquance sociale à
probabilité ne soit pas au niveau
départemental mais régional zonal ou
nationale selon les cas est-ce que vous
souhaitez monsieur rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs députés j'ai vu les amendes
déposer que ce soit inscrit dans le
rapport annexé je suis d'accord donc je
donne un avis favorable je dirais un
brocard à ses amendements qui
prévoierait d'encadrer la réforme de la
police nationale maintenant faut-il
regarder les taux d'élucidation BC la
criminalité organisée se transformer tes
technologiquement constaté tous ensemble
je dis à monsieur cioti qui me parle de
réforme de la Playstation le
rassemblement national qu'est-ce que
vous faites bon bah très bien et qu'on
propose une sorte une vraie forme qui
permet de comprendre qu'il y a à la fois
de la délinquance étrangère qui a
évidemment du renseignement car
évidemment de la course internationale
qui a évidemment la délinquance le
territoriale et que tout ça
malheureusement aujourd'hui est lié et
ben on fait une réforme de la police
nationale qui est souhaitée par beaucoup
de monde donc on a l'occasion d'en
reparler mais je veux dire que je suis
tout à fait prêt à aller vers
l'encadrement de la réforme de la police
nationale puisque je l'ai proposé
moi-même d'ailleurs au Sénat et que nous
pourrons discuter à l'envie de ces
modifications dans le rapport annexé
merci Monsieur le mist trois
observations d'abord le texte court moi
je le revendique c'est ce que je vous ai
demandé cet été au mois de juillet c'est
ce que j'ai demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur c'est ce que j'ai demandé
également à tous les ministres qui sont
qui passeront dans la commission des
lois c'est aussi un gage de la qualité
de nos travaux de passe disperser de pas
étudier n'importe quoi et de pouvoir
aller au fond des choses lorsqu'on
utilise des textes donc 15 articles je
pense que c'est des bons textes de loi
et c'est des choses sur lesquels on peut
travailler sérieusement ici devant notre
commission c'est une exigence que je
recondurai pour tous les autres textes
en tout cas que je vous demanderai donc
je salue cette le respect de cette
condition qu'on avait posé au début de
l'été ensuite pour ce qui concerne
différentes revendications notamment sur
le texte sur les Jeux Olympiques pour
les questions d'ordre public c'est à
cette occasion que nous l'examinerons
sur des questions de vidéos pour
lesquelles on a une autre mission
d'information qui a été lancée et qui
est conduite par Monsieur Gosselin et
Messieurs la tombe et avec aussi
quelques travaux à conduire de la
commission des lois moi j'étais ce
weekend à Marseille ou Lord public et
très bien mis en œuvre pour la question
du respect des des matchs des matchs qui
sont extrêmement difficiles les matchs
qui sont les matchs européens qui
rassemble plus de 67.000 personnes et
qui donnent à voir aussi ce que la
France peut faire et peut réussir dans
l'organisation des grandes compétitions
et qui dans la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques où la Coupe du monde de rugby
et bien donne des satisfactions
importantes dans le cadre de ce que nous
pouvons prévoir c'est également le cas
sur les questions des manifestations
alors on a et moi j'ai une pensée
également pour les 66 gendarmes qui ont
des blessés ce week-end on a des
discussions on aura certainement des
discussions mais qu'il y ait des
manifestations d'ampleur avec des
désordres tels que ceux qu'on a connu ce
week-end sans aucun incident grave sans
aucun incident grave dans notre pays je
pense ça donne à voir aussi de la
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre qui
n'est pas si mauvaise dans notre pays
c'est une deuxième observation et une
troisième observation
pour ce qui concerne pour ce qui
concerne la mission d'information sur la
police je vous remercie d'avoir pour le
rapport que vous demanderez public
auprès de notre commission le rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration vous avez fait mention
d'un deuxième rapport de l'Inspection
générale de la justice et si vous en
êtes d'accord vous m'avez une lettre
dans lequel vous confirmez les propos de
libre choix par le magistrat enquêteur
du service d'enquête qu'il requiert en
application de l'article 12 du code de
procédure pénale si vous en êtes
d'accord la lettre que vous avez
adressée aux gardes des sauts sur ce
sujet je la rendrai publique aux
différents membres de la commission des
lois comme ça chacun aura un écrit une
preuve un gage de ce que de ce à quoi
vous êtes engagé et qui d'ailleurs n'est
que la traduction de nos travaux puisque
vous l'avez dit il n'y a pas de
modification législatives sur ce point
je le ferai diffuser dans la journée aux
différentes commissaires aux lois je
vais donner la parole différents
orateurs pour une durée 2 minutes chacun
mais madame Julie le chanteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur n'est pas à la
hauteur quand on prétend par deux fois
que les violences faites aux femmes sont
les grandes causes du quinquennat en
effet vous avez voulu au travers de
l'article 7 de ce projet abordé le sujet
des outrages sexistes très bien c'est en
effet un problème de société qu'une
femme ne puisse pas se sentir en
sécurité dans les rues dans les
transports en commun ou aux abords de
chez elle c'est un sujet évidemment
primordial qui est car il participe à
l'insécurité persistante à laquelle les
françaises doivent faire face tous les
jours les insultes sur le physique sur
le fait de porter des vêtements comme
une jupe ou un décolleté le harcèlement
et qui plus est
à répétition à cause d'un regard ou de
simples faits de se trouver là n'est
plus tenable alors Monsieur le Ministre
expliquez-nous pourquoi vous ne créez
pas un véritable arsenal législatif
contre ce fléau en faisant comme
l'Espagne par exemple qui considère cela
comme un délit pourquoi ne pas vous
emparer sincèrement de ce sujet pourquoi
ne faites-vous pas preuve de bon sens et
d'une réelle volonté politique tout
simplement pourquoi ne sanctionnez-vous
pas plus sévèrement la récidive pourquoi
n’inscrivez-vous pas ces auteurs au
fichiers des délinquants sexuels
pourquoi laissez-vous les auteurs
d'outrage sans tirer avec de simples
amandes ces amandes qui d'ailleurs
peuvent même être forfaitaire et être
réglé rapidement et pour un montant
dérisoire en fait avec vous on peut
injurier harceler une française sans
problème si on se balade avec des
billets de 200 euros dans la poche
encore un avantage pour les dealers de
drogues qui sont rarement payés par
carte toutes ces questions vous vous en
doutez sont à la base des amendements
qui sont ceux du rassemblement national
puisque vous n'avez pas la volonté de
défendre les libertés la sécurité des
femmes de notre pays nous nous allons
nous en occuper je vous remercie
Monsieur Thomas porte
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre au moment où nous ouvrons le
débat sur ce projet de loi d'orientation
et programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur impossible de passer sous
silence les événements du weekend
dernier à Sainte-Soline
comme l'a évoqué tout à l'heure mon
collègue Hugo Bernal ici et oui ce sont
des faits graves qui se sont passés une
fois de plus la question de la doctrine
du maintien de l'ordre se pose nous
déposerons d'ailleurs un amendement dans
ce sens en fin de garantir le droit de
manifester aujourd'hui entravé dans
notre pays par un usage disproportionné
de la force nous demanderons aussi
l'interdiction dès le BD et je vous
rassure monsieur le ministre nous
porterons aussi l'interdiction et la
suppression de la BAC la répression
policière de ce week-end lors de la
manifestation légitime contre la mise en
place de bassines sur le département des
Deux-Sèvres et est inacceptable une élue
de la République notre collègue député
elvisa belluco frappé par les forces de
police un jeune homme victime de tir de
LBD en plein visage des dizaines de
garde à vue mais de quoi parle-t-on
monsieur le ministre d'une manifestation
de militants écologistes contre la
caparation des ressources en eau pour
une minorité et sûrement pas des côtes
terrorisme comme vous l'avez évoqué lors
d'une conférence de presse une notion
d'ailleurs qui n'existe pas dans le
droit français et ne peut en rien
correspondre à la notion de terrorisme
et dictée par la directive européenne de
2019 les mots ont un sens et en disant
cela toutes celles et ceux qui les
reprennent à leur compte minorent à la
fois ce qu'est le terrorisme et insulte
celles et ceux qui en sont victimes une
fois de plus vous avez fait le choix de
la tension pour évacuer la question de
fond au moment où votre gouvernement
refuse d'agir sur la question climatique
1700 policiers sur place un dispositif
totalement disproportionné je remarque
que ce gouvernement est bien plus
intéressé par imprimer les mobilisations
sociales écologiques pendant que des
manifestations d'extrême droite se
déroulent dans le pays en toute
tranquillité monsieur le ministre où
était les policiers lors des
manifestations racistes organisées à
Lyon Rennes et Paris par des groupes
muscules identité à la semaine dernière
comment se fait-il que ces
manifestations ait pu se dérouler alors
même que des slogans racistes y étaient
prononcés monsieur le ministre le droit
de manifester est une liberté
constitutionnelle ma question est simple
allez vous retirer vos propos qualifiant
ces mobilisations des côtés
du maintien de l'ordre pour permettre
aux gens de manifester en toute sécurité
madame Mathilde les Jonquières en
visioconférence
à Monsieur Philippe la tombe alors
pardon oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous sommes avec le
groupe démocrate très satisfait du
montant que vous allez débloquer pour
améliorer le quotidien des forces de
l'ordre notamment sur la partie
cybersécurité technologies système
d'information pour permettre à nos
forces de l'ordre de pouvoir intervenir
de façon la plus efficace possible
notamment dans des sphères qui sont
nouvelles celles de la de la cyber
sécurité notamment la question est
remontée par l'ensemble de l'écosystème
allez vous prendre en compte le fait que
ces améliorations c'est modifications
technologiques doit faire l'objet d'une
forme de souveraineté de la part du
ministère de l'Intérieur et donc plutôt
adressé autant que faire ce peu la
commande publique vers des entreprises
qui permettraient de pouvoir maintenir
un niveau de conformité et un niveau de
souveraineté suffisant pour pouvoir
assurer à l'avenir au-delà des 5 ans la
capacité du ministère de l'intérieur des
forces de l'ordre de pouvoir continuer à
exercer leur mission dans ce dans le
cyberespace et aussi de pouvoir
maintenir des systèmes d'information de
façon autonome la question aujourd'hui
est remontée de façon de façon accrue
votre collègue qui appartient au groupe
démocrate Jean-Noël Barrault a expliqué
qu'il ne pourrait pas y avoir de
cybersécurité sans souveraineté nous
voudrions savoir si effectivement c'est
aussi la vision du ministère de
l'Intérieur je vous remercie
merci Monsieur romain bobry
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre alors
vous allez avoir l'impression que je me
répète mais je vous rassure ce n'est pas
une impression rien dans ce texte
n'apporte la moindre mesure pour faire
face pour faire face pardon au risque
psychosociaux or si vous souhaitez que
les institutions régaliennes de sécurité
publique soient pleinement mobilisée il
faut que nos forces de l'ordre
retrouvent du sens dans leur métier et
le soutien d'une hiérarchie devenu
comptable et ici même il y a quelques
semaines monsieur le ministre je vous ai
interrogé au sujet des suicides chez
forces de l'ordre et même pas l'ombre
d'une réponse j'ai donc abordé ce sujet
la semaine dernière lors des questions
gouvernement cette question vous était
adressée mais la réponse fut apportée
par la ministre déléguée à la
citoyenneté la réponse je sais pas si on
peut appeler ce terme de réponse nous
avons surtout assisté à deux minutes
d'agonie de la part de Sonia bac S qui
manifestement s'était trompé de fiches
alors le fait qu'elle se soit
ridiculisée devant la France pourrait
prêter à sourire si le sujet n'était pas
si grave et si derrière ces drames il
n'y avait pas notamment des drames
familiaux qui pour notamment des
familles et les enfants qui vivent avec
l'absence de celui qui a décidé d'en
finir alors monsieur le ministre avant
de répondre à mon intervention je vous
demande avant tout de penser à eux
mettons la politique deux minutes de
côté vous êtes le ministre de
l'Intérieur seulement depuis deux ans je
ne vous tiens pas comme responsable de
cette vague de suicide qui a lieu depuis
20 ans mais vous le deviendriez vous
aussi si vous n'agissez pas car chaque
semaine où nous perdons du temps sur le
sujet des responsables hiérarchiques
continuent à agir en toute impunité
mettant une pression sur des agents dans
leur propre intérêt personnel mettant en
placard celui dont la tête dépasserait
ou en poussant les plus fragiles d'entre
eux à commettre l'irréparable en 20 ans
je vous le redis plus de 1200 suicide
rien qu'en police nationale alors
Monsieur le Ministre ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est est-ce qu'on change de
méthode on se contente d'un tweet
lorsqu'un monde des forces de l'ordre
fait traverser une balle de 9 mm au
travers de sa boîte crânienne je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur le ministre
il a mené je vais travailler je vais
faire une observation et puis une
demande une observation c'est que ces 15
milliards qui sont donc dédiés à la
police doivent contribuer à
l'amélioration aussi de l'oeuvre de
justice évidemment on ne peut pas
l'imaginer autrement et à ce propos je
voulais rappeler que j'aurais apprécié
qu'il y a une vraie solidarité
gouvernementale du pouvoir judiciaire et
l'autorité de législatif et de
l'autorité judiciaire pour contrer les
propos populistes que l'on nous que l'on
a pu entendre très grave sur le
caractère expéditif que doit revêtir
l'œuvre de justice
les responsabilités de tels médias et
les dégâts qu'ils font dans l'opinion
publique doit être me semble-t-il
dénoncer totalement
et cela pour vous dire que nous
demandons simplement que
le pouvoir
[Musique]
que le pouvoir judiciaire soit protégé
et que les juges d'instructions comme
les procureurs et bien soient libres de
disposer des moyens de la police
judiciaire dont ils ont besoin sans en
référer au préfet ça nous paraît tout à
fait indispensable nous avions déposé un
amendement en ce sens
je ne veux pas non plus ne pas vous
remercier au nom de mon groupe sur
l'accueil que vous faites à
l'amélioration du dispositif que vous
aviez prévu qui était la mise en place
d'un comité d'éthique le collège de
déontologie dans l'applique dans la
suite de la loi 2016 est un pas
important dans la mesure où des
personnalités extérieures viendront
travailler avec les professionnels du
ministère de la police sur l'ensemble
des compétences du ministère et là je
vous rejoins la seule chose que je vous
demande c'est que l'arrêté ministérielle
qui sera pris puisse être mis en
consultation comme cela est de
dorénavant de plus en plus demandé et
par les universitaires et par les
associations et par les législateurs je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Yoann
oui monsieur le ministre vous
l'annoncier avec votre loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous allions voir ce que
nous allions voir à la Sarko 2016 vous
nous promettiez de sortir les gros bras
mais voilà la réalité est là si personne
ne peut nier que votre projet de loi
comporte quelques avancées appréciable
personne ne peut nier en revanche ça
faiblesse alors vous me direz les
parlementaires que nous sommes sont là
pour enrichir ce projet certes et
j'appelle d'ailleurs de mes vœux à ce
que le gouvernement donne un avis
favorable aux excellents amendements
préparés par les députés du
rassemblement national peut-être même
que les députés LR retrouveront ici un
brin de courage et votre rond aux
amendements une hypothèse tout aussi
crédible qu'une fin de la haine du flic
chez nos collègues d'extrême gauche mais
il n'est pas interdit pardon de rêver
pas interdit de rêver qu'un jour la
droite défende enfin avec nous la
sécurité des Français alors voyez-vous
monsieur le ministre si nous allons
proposer évidemment des amendements pour
tenter de corriger les faiblesses de
votre projet de loi nous ne pourrons
malheureusement pas lui donner l'axe que
ce projet de loi mériterait car de la
veut même du président de la commission
des lois le périmètre de votre projet de
loi est trop restreint en effet ce
dernier déclaré ircevable un certain
nombre d'amendements plus précisément il
les a déclarés comme étant des cavaliers
législatives sans lien avec votre texte
le temps méconté alors deux exemples
rapides premièrement le renforcement du
régime de rétention de sûreté déclare et
cavalier sans lier indirect ou indirect
avec votre texte le renforcement des
sanctions liées à l'idéologie islamiste
déclaré cavaliers sans lien direct ou
indirect avec votre texte pourtant
Monsieur le Ministre dans votre projet
vous soulignez je cite qu'au-delà des
crises notre société devra également
être plus robiste dans sa réponse à
toutes les formes de délinquance et de
criminalité du terrorisme et de la
criminalité organisée jusqu'aux actes de
petites délinquance monsieur le ministre
à ma question est la suivante est-il
normal selon vous que les représentants
du peuple se voient opposer une fin d'y
recevabilité non justifiée quand ils
introduisent de nouvelles transition
pour protéger les citoyens qui en
entendent tant besoin merci alors il
reçoit à 8 et j'en suis seul et lire
aussi habilité elle s'explique deux
titres par rapport à ce que vous avez
décrit d'abord lorsque vous modifiez des
dispositions du code de sécurité
intérieure sur la rétention de sûreté
sur des lois anti-terroriste laissez-moi
vous dire qu'on n'est pas sur un texte
antiterroriste on est sur un texte de
polygénéral et de programmation du
ministère intérieur et donc vous
amendements à ce titre sont-ils
recevables quant à l'amendement qui
écrivait tout un chapitre sur ce que
vous avez décrit l'idéologie islamique
radicale a supposer qu'elle était
recevable dans un texte suite été sur le
texte séparatisme or ce n'est pas le cas
ici il est tout aussi recevable et donc
je maintiens avec fermeté et avec
beaucoup d'aplomb les désirer sa
politique j'ai prononcé à cet égard
monsieur Benjamin Lucas merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur je suis l'élu de
Mantes-la-Jolie ou le 6 décembre 2018
151 jeunes lycéens pour la plupart âgés
de 12 à 21 ans ont été forcés à rester à
genouillés main derrière la tête pendant
plusieurs dizaines de minutes
et un policier filmant la scène avait eu
ce propos voilà une classe qui se tient
ça alors ma question est simple je crois
qu'il y a un impensé dans votre action
et dans cette loi c'est la façon dont
nous pouvons restaurer le lien de
confiance entre nos concitoyens et la
police on peut avoir des divergences
idéologiques nous en avons elles ont été
exprimées par mes collègues mais moi je
voudrais vous demander ce que je réponds
au maire de famille qui m'ont contacté
pendant ma campagne qui sont que je
rencontre tous les jours sur le terrain
qui ont la peur au ventre quand elle
voit passer depuis cet épisode un
fourgon de police dans leur quartier
comment je peux leur répondre quand nous
assistons à de telles actes et que rien
n'a été fait ni dans vos mots ni dans
vos actes depuis pour que ce genre
d'humiliation terrible pour des jeunes
je le répète de 12 à 21 ans ne se
reproduisent plus
merci monsieur le ministre pour la
réponse à ces questions
merci pas beaucoup de questions je
renverrai pas sur la l'épisode de ce
weekend je constate que vous avez pas un
mot sur les 66 gendarmes qui ont été
blessés dans quelques-uns on la mâchoire
écrasée peut-être qui ne pourront plus
parler de leur vie donc dans les
communiqués de presse que j'ai créé son
public
je vraiment je regrette qu'au départ un
mot d'équilibre pour pour ces pères et
mère de famille qui ont subi une extrême
violence une extrême violence et je
crois que les images les images qu'on
que les Français ont vu ont constaté
d'une part l'extrême violence qu'on
subit les gendarmes pour une
manifestation qui était interdite et
validée comme cette interdiction par le
juge je réussis de rappeler et
deuxièmement chacun a vu les
provocations
de certains élus et ça a été vu par la
France entière je crois et que je crois
que c'est des excuses qu'il fallait
présenter et pas des insultes aux
policiers et je vais vous dire je
mais monsieur bernalicis monsieur
bernalicis un député c'est pas une
immunité vivante et de respecter toutes
les règles de la République Monsieur
monsieur bennetti ce qu'on veut te
respecter il faut être respectable il
doit respecter toutes les règles de la
République toutes les règles de la
République Monsieur bernalicis monsieur
Bernadette de la République enfin vous
avez chacun pu prononcé des mots qui
sont des mots fermes qui sont des mots
qui vous engagent dans le plus grand des
silence et des calmes que j'ai maintenu
donc si vous pouvez faire autant lors de
la réponse du ministre je vous en
remercierai non non mais s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît le ministre il a
souffert de vos observations de vos
commentaires qu'ils partagent
probablement pas toutes d'accord on peut
le dire voilà donc maintenant vous le
laissez répondre et il trouve que le
ministre est par ailleurs lui aussi
parlementaire donc il ne dévalue pas le
travail des parlementaire mais je pense
que tous les députés et tous les
sénateurs ne sont pas au dessus des lois
de la République et alors les députés de
laupestre ne sont pas au dessus des lois
de tous les autres députés non plus
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut respecter
les règles de la République il n'y a pas
les règles des uns les règles des autres
il y a pourquoi de la République cette
manifestation était interdite je ne vous
ferai pas je ne vous ferai pas
l'historique de cette infrastructure
agricole qui j'appelle a été validé par
des gouvernements qui ne sont pas les
nôtres avec des députés qui se disaient
écologistes qui étaient ministre à
l'époque on est des autorisations et je
ne vous validerai pas le fait que par
ailleurs le juge qui parfois nous
interdit d'interdire de manifestations
de les a validés et je veux vous dire
ici que je suis con je suis fier de la
façon dont les gendarmes se sont
comportés tout le monde a vu qu'ils ont
subi des provocations des attaques à
coup de pierre à coups de cocktail
Motors à coup de pieux et ça n'a rien à
voir avec des manifestations qui
relèvent de Gandhi vous n'êtes pas
Gandhi vous étiez manifestement du côté
de jeux de ceux qui ont attaqué de ce
qu'on va attaquer les gendarmes à coups
de pierre de 15 cm et qui ont des
mâchoires et des mâchoires écrasées je
veux vous dire ici je veux vous dire ici
qu'il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de pouvoir
extraordinaire au-delà de la loi des
parlementaires et je pense que la
grandeur du parlementaire c'est
justement de respecter les lois qui sont
votées par le peuple souverain et vous
malheureusement je constate que
indépendamment de ce week-end était
manifestations violentes que nous avons
vu du comportement je crois inacceptable
c'est mon jugement personnel d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont en
effet élus et que tout le monde a pu
constater qu'il y avait pas eu de
provocation de la part des gendarmes et
que c'était bien averse qui avait été
fait je veux redire ici je regrette
profondément profondément que vous
n'avez pas un mot pour ces pères et
maire de famille qui ont fait leur
travail de fonctionnaires et d'ailleurs
je veux vous dire que dans toutes vos
interventions j'entends beaucoup de
critiques sur la police et gendarmerie
j'ai pas encore entendu un soutien ce
qui montre sans doute un inconscient qui
est tout à fait qui est tout à fait
conscient donc je ne rentrerai pas dans
cette
ultime provocation je crois que vous
auriez été grandi de reconnaître que ce
weekend n'était pas très flatteur et
l'écologie est sans doute renoble pour
être prise en effet par l’hyper violence
sur le deuxième sujet qui évoque le
rassemblant national sur les suicides
dans la police et dans la gendarmerie
puisqu'il y a aussi des suicides
évidemment dans la gendarmerie nationale
je voudrais associer d'autres
administrations qui connaissent des
armes les douaniers par exemple c'est
aussi c'est aussi le cas je n'ai
minimise pas du tout ils ont beaucoup de
raisons vous le savez bien aussi des
raisons professionnelles sans aucune
espèce de doute parfois aussi des
raisons personnelles vous savez aussi
qui se complètent ça peut tout à fait
arriver nous avons à la fois des
difficultés de manque de psychologue au
sein de l'administration de la police
nationale c'est tout à fait vrai donc la
lotmi monsieur le député prévoit
l'augmentation recrutement de ces
psychologues 40 parents pour la police
et c'est un premier point puisque quand
on vit une scène de crime quand on a des
difficultés extrêmement fortes qu'on
regarde des images P2 pornographiques
qu'on voit je pense aux policiers qui
ont vu le corps de la petite là on n'est
pas toujours par manque de moyens
débriefés psychologiquement et ça c'est
un premier problème de névrose et de
choc qui peuvent évidemment s'accumuler
il y a un management qui peut être en
nocif je passe mon temps également à le
dire et il convient de voir que dans
l'ensemble de la chaîne de hiérarchie
doit se sentir concerné et ce management
qui ne peut pas être nocif et vous êtes
tout à fait raison de dire que nous
devons prendre les devoirs d'alertes
nécessaires faut-il améliorer les choses
sans aucun doute et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'un amendement soit un rapport demandé
au gouvernement sur les suicides dans
les forces de l'orge donnera un avis
favorable et je propose effectivement
que avec les commissaires aux lois des
deux assemblées on puisse en discuter
évidemment il y a aussi une question de
formation c'est bien qu'il y a pas cette
formateur dans la police nationale
initiale ça s'est beaucoup amélioré
continue c'est évidemment une question
qui se pose et donc nous recrutons c'est
un plan extrêmement important de former
les formateurs et de recruter c'est ce
que prévoit aussi la loopy on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler sans doute dans
le dans le débat je ne veux donc pas les
je ne veux donc pas les les sous-estimer
bien évidemment et je partage la peine
de chacune et de chacun des des des vies
qui évidemment sont retirés sans doute
parce que le monde professionnel ils
évolue qui est extrêmement violent n'a
pas été au rendez-vous de leur
accompagnement et d'ailleurs pour la
quasi intégralité de ces policiers ou de
ces gendarmes qui se suicident je suis
en contact personnel avec la famille
j'en fais pas de suite particulièrement
mais je pense que c'est un drame pour
chacune et pour chacun d'entre nous bien
évidemment quel que soit ceux qui gère
le ministère de l'Intérieur bien sûr sur
la question que pose monsieur la tombe
sur finalement la notre façon d'imaginer
la souveraineté et notamment dans le
dans le cyber c'est à dire dans les
normes cyber que nous allons imposer moi
je pense que c'est une question
essentielle alors si je prends l'exemple
par la preuve le rasoir à dos du futur
malgré le code des marchés publics vous
constaterez que c'est intégralement des
sociétés françaises qui ont gagné le
marché puisque nous avons un gros le
gros qui porte qui est Airbus et de
chacun c'est à quel point nous pouvons
avoir confiance dans cette très grande
entreprise le téléphone que nous
équipons chacun des policiers des
gendarmes c'est une société
d'Aix-en-Provence qui s'appelle
crosscall qui va d'ailleurs travailler
en lien avec avec Airbus c'est Bouygues
et Orange qui vont faire les réseaux
bref vous aurez constaté que sur
l'ensemble de Capgemini qui va faire un
symptôme de d'accompagnement également
comme d'ailleurs Atos vous voyez que par
exemple de marché à 2 milliards c'est
intégralement français alors la
difficulté que Camille c'est
qu'évidemment que le code marchés
publics vous savez bien il permet pas de
sélectionner que des entreprises
françaises donc on doit faire trois
types de choses d'abord on doit avoir un
ministère de l'Intérieur comment on peut
développer les filières de souveraineté
donc j'ai demandé au secrétaire général
du ministère par exemple de recréer une
filière de travailler avec la filière
économique pour faire notamment une
souveraineté entière sur les munitions
ce qui est pas notre cas aujourd'hui par
exemple ou dans l'équipement des
policiers ou des gendarmes vous savez
que leur équipement jusqu'à ce que je
donnais une mise intérieure était fait
et fabriquer un Madagascar désormais le
changement donc il y a des choses qui
sont faciles à faire facile à faire
parce que nous avons connaissons les
entreprises aujourd'hui avec des
commandes en leur expl pense que nous
allons faire les moyens qu'on va y
mettre en utilisant un nombre de choses
en écoutant aussi leur sujet par exemple
pour acheter des voitures extrêmement
rapides on a pu définir en amont avec la
gendarmerie nationale qui sont nos
besoins et on a pu avoir l'Alpine à la
fin c'était mieux que d'avoir sans doute
une autre société puisque l'Alpine est
fabriquée vous le savez à Dieppe et qui
a relancé en partie d'ailleurs la
production de ces voitures donc pareil
pour les 5008 donc c'est comment on
définit très en amont les filières
appliquer à ces nouvelles technologies
pour que la souveraineté se soit pas
quelque chose qui nous impose de Chine
d'Israël ou des États-Unis il faut
d'abord que nous puissions dire à
chacune et à chacun voilà ce que la loi
va ce qui sera autorisé à faire demain
si demain et vous avez un rapport sur ce
sujet on en reparlera dans le projet de
loi spécifique sans doute aux Jeux
Olympiques si demain on permet de faire
fonctionner l'intelligence artificielle
sur les images de caméra vidéoprotection
c'est un choix législateur c'est mieux
quand même de montrer qu'on y travaille
et permettre aux investisseurs et à se
susciter de s'intéresser au marché
français deuxièmement à nous de mettre
des règles et je sais que vous serez
attentif pour que ce soit des sociétés
qui travaillent dans un certain esprit
d'utilisation des données ou des images
et pas les autres troisièmement moi je
crois beaucoup on aura l'occasion
d'avoir ce débat sans doute dans
l'hémicycle lorsqu'on parlera d'article
4 notamment à des normes que nous
pourrions éditer pas des labels vous
voyez ce que je veux dire on peut parler
des labels mais derrière chaque level il
y a sans doute déjà un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont derrière et ils sont
tout à fait respectables bien sûr mais
je crois que le cyber c'est comme un
incendie dans le monde réel c'est à dire
que si un incendie se propage dans un
hôpital public ou dans une entreprise
dans une maison on voit bien que pour le
contre carré cette incendie il faut
mettre des normes et c'est pour ça qu'on
a posé des normes incendies à l'époque
on a dit bah voilà on peut permettre une
certaine assurance on peut pas mettre un
certain
interventions des sapeurs-pompiers s'il
y a déjà un certain nombre de normes
qu'on impose à tel bâtiment moi je crois
que c'est pas le cas de la loop mini
d'aujourd'hui je veux bien l'avouer mais
ça va être le cas cette réflexion pour
demain et après-demain à coup sûr
comment on peut imposer un certain
nombre de normes incendies de normes
cyber à une entreprise à une
collectivité locale à un particulier
pourquoi pas et qui définit les normes
définit le marché et si c'est nous les
français qui définissons dans notre
droit quels sont les normes que nous
souhaitons imposer nous allons pouvoir
aussi accompagner en faisant un petit
clin d'œil à nos investisseurs et nos
sociétés françaises ou européennes à
répondre à des normes que nous
définissons et pas subir les normes
américaines subir les lames chinoises
aussi bien les normes d'autres pays
troisièmement je terminerai par la zone
question qui est quand même extrêmement
extrêmement passionnante peut-être que
vous l'avez tel que vous l'avez évoqué
nous avons dans le rapport qui prévoit
la programmation mais c'est à
l'intérieur un certain nombre de choses
qui ne sont pas législatives je les dis
c'est lequel la réforme pollutionnelle
c'est le cas aussi d'organisation du
ministère et pour la première fois nous
allons créer deux directions ministères
de l'Intérieur qui n'existaient pas
copions ainsi le modèle militaire une
direction qui va être en lien avec la
recherche
ça c'est un point très important dans
l'occasion d'en discuter et une
direction qui va s'occuper du
partenariat avec les entreprises nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui ministère
d'intérieur alors que nous travaillons
les métiers d'incendie du secours les
métiers évidemment de la sécurité les
munitions évidemment le cyber nous
n'avons pas la technologie nous n'avons
pas de direction en charge des
coopérations économiques comment on
travaille avec les PME très en amont
comment on comprend les difficultés de
chacun et donc nous créons aussi une
direction
du partenariat économique au sein du
ministère intérieur pour justement
prévoir ce genre de normes que vous
souhaitez voilà je pense que je tiendrai
par là monsieur le Président dire juste
effectivement que je ne suis pas en
charge de la recevabilité des
amendements et donc mais comme le
président
Sacha oui du salut m'a expliqué de sa
recevabilité je dirais pas plus loin